Boom,
and we live just like that.
That's what I like.
That's what I like to man.
We're sitting here.
I'm here with George Perez and right
when I was coming here,
my neighbor right over here,
uh,
just told me there's some black suv
drive it down the street.
They got battering rams,
a black helicopters.
And then Jamie said there's swat crews.
Some shit's going down.
George Perez A.
I tweeted,
let people know you're in the era.
Did you have location services turned
on?
You've got to turn that shit off man.
They find you.
They find you probably will find you.
They probably do.
That's why Aria,
I'm convinced that's why art should
fear.
Went to a flip phone.
Has Gps on him,
doesn't want them tracking them.
Those mushroom drops and he leaves
everywhere.
And
so there's something going on.
So while this podcast is happening,
some shit is going on very close to us
here.
We're in woodland hills.
So,
uh,
somewhere in this area,
somewhere in the eight.
One eight.
I was nervous coming over here because
of the area.
Really?
Yeah.
I haven't been here since like
[inaudible] 98.
This is a fucked up area.
Well,
we used to sell speed to people
received a
visit.
I remember.
They're like,
don't turn right to not go that way.
Like you don't want to go back to see
what what you planted.
Oh,
it's here.
It's here.
Speed is a weird one,
man.
You know they had this statistic the
other day on how many fucking people are
on adderall.
Oh Shit.
She's just.
Speed is just fucking speed.
There's a statistic that I posted
yesterday that's the most disturbing one
though.
Rhonda.
Patrick.
Dr Rhonda.
Patrick put it up.
There's more people on pain pills today.
Then use tobacco foc.
Think about that.
That's how crazy the pain pill business
has gone.
Think about all the dip,
all the people that chew all the people
that smoke cigars and cigarettes.
All that combined.
There's more people on pain pills
and it's weird because they took
cigarettes away from baseball.
Remember the use of smoke in the
eighties?
You could smoke in baseball and you
could dip.
I don't remember.
I remember you could dip.
Can't dip anymore.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I don't know about professional.
I know you can't dip in college,
but days to smoke cigarettes in the
games in the dugouts.
Wow.
And I only know because sometimes I stay
up late and watch espn and I'm like,
Oh shit,
you could smoke back then.
So you watch like an old game and
they'll show him still smoking.
It was like espn has classics and it was
like a classics like world series and I
think it was Reggie Jackson smoking in
the dug out.
Look at it,
look at that right there.
He didn't.
There you go.
Joy's a dugout cigarette.
What years that from?
Jamie says 1987.
Nineteen 87 game.
Yeah.
They used to smoke cigarettes and then
spit.
Always chewing and spitting and now
they're popping pills and getting
concussions.
Well they definitely are popping pills
apparently.
That's another big problem.
Adderall is a big problem with a
baseball.
It helps them focus and concentrate on
hitting the ball better.
That's just fucking crazy to me.
How they prescribe you speed to get
smarter.
It accelerates well for apparently when
who's does that?
Does that mean that's not a thought?
A Dang somebody.
Um,
when you,
uh,
when you have add,
which is real debatable whether or not
that shit's real or how many people
actually,
I mean,
is it just people with energy?
Is it just people were bored,
they don't want to concentrate on
whatever the fuck you want them to
concentrate on.
I mean,
I don't exactly know what add really is
because I think it's severely obese over
prescribed by everyone's measures.
But when you have it,
when you give them speed,
it helps them calm down somehow or
another.
I don't get,
it seems it must be like a,
a focus speed they give or like a
special something they found in there
because I'm back in my days and I did
speed.
I couldn't focus on shit.
Maybe that's because you don't have it
though because you don't have add
whatever that means.
But if add doesn't exist and maybe it's
just something that makes everybody
focus.
Well I think add most likely is just
there's a bunch of behaviors.
There's a bunch of different ways people
behave and there's a bunch of ways their
mind works and some people they like to
stay calm and focus on one thing and be
like peace and quiet and other people
are scattered as fuck and they're
thinking about a million different
things and they can't concentrate speed
apparently for those people helps them
concentrate.
But the question is like,
if someone is like,
I had a next door neighbor and uh,
this next door neighbor,
his kid was just a regular fucking kid
and they put the kid on Prozac.
It was really weird,
man.
They were like,
ah,
you can't concentrate.
He's just,
he's all over the place.
So we,
you know,
we put them on and I,
I couldn't even talk to the dude.
I was just like,
this is crazy.
You're medicating a.
He was like an eight or nine year old
kid.
He's just a fucking kid.
Most kids when they go to school,
they don't want to pay attention to
whatever the fuck the teacher's talking
about.
No,
I,
I woulda,
I woulda got prescribed.
Or was that district called diagnosed?
I got diagnosed as kindergarten.
Yeah,
I think I would have to for sure if I
had that guy for a dad,
he definitely would have put me on some
medication.
That's weird.
I remember the first time I heard of
add,
like I thought it was a gang and I was
like,
can we get along with those foods?
They're like,
Nah,
foe,
it's a focusing shit.
And I was just like,
Oh,
what the hell?
A focusing shit.
So the kind of speed that you would sell
these people out here,
like what kind of speed was at back
then?
They used to be called crank,
you remember?
Do remember crying?
What is that?
I don't know.
I think crank is just like the best part
of the strict nine because it's made out
of.
Am I right?
The best part of.
Yeah.
And we used to sell the peanut butter
one.
It was a peanut butter one.
It was,
it was weird because like back in those
days,
speed had a taste that was just awful.
It was like rotten.
A cactus cooler.
That's what it tasted like.
Like a rotten cactus cooler.
You ever left?
The cactus cooler out.
That's it.
Oh yeah.
And so it's,
it was made with a peanut butter taste.
That was weird.
Yeah.
I mean I don't remember who we were
getting it from.
I just remember the guy going
[inaudible] we used to hit it out of a
bong so it was due.
We were crazy.
And I'd be like,
fuck this shit.
Tastes like peanut butter.
So yeah,
I started focusing on peanut butter
sandwiches.
You focused.
That's so bizarre.
So when,
when you would do that back then,
um,
you would have to like how,
how do you get into the speed business?
Like you'd have to find somebody who's
cooking.
Yeah,
I mean yeah,
it was weird because a,
I'm like,
what?
Twenty years old.
I just left my lady for being a tweaker,
like a crazy one and then it just got me
involved and be like,
no,
fuck this.
I need to make money.
I need to make money and my buddies go
ahead.
So I was to say,
so she was a crazy tweaker.
She wasn't like hard core,
like still to this day,
still alive.
Still do.
She has seven kids from six guys.
Oh good.
Ken.
She's that kind of girl.
That's just pretty where a guy will be
like,
I'll pay for whatever you want and she's
with it.
Wow.
I'm just happy.
I was the first one and I got out.
Man,
that's a weird one.
Right.
But people that are on speed,
I hung out with a dude recently that was
on speed.
He didn't want him and he was on speed,
but you could tell because he would do
things like he was saying that we've
talked to him.
He turned like real quick,
kind of collect themselves and turn real
quick and like why we were meeting.
A couple of my buddies were like,
why is he moving so fast?
And then trying to calm himself down and
like he,
he was driving us and when he was
driving he would make like these quick
turns.
I'm incorrect trying to calm himself.
Like this guy's on fucking speed,
man.
Going on as if he made a move and then
he looked at shoe to be like,
fuck this.
You know,
I'm on it.
Okay.
I mean,
I wouldn't look at the way he was
turning it was like he heard a loud
noise,
like a for everything he did.
All your senses are up,
senses are up,
you're alert to anything and everything.
It's up.
I mean,
Hitler gave it to his troops,
right?
Yeah.
They say he invented it.
I don't know if that's true.
Um,
I think it was invented during that
time.
I don't think it was Hitler.
Hitler was in the lab.
I've got it.
That's why as much,
that's just so little results.
I've got to keep this one
clean.
No,
I think they invented it during that
era.
And uh,
I know they gave it to the kamikaze is
too.
That's how they got the kamikaze is to
fly those planes into battle ships.
They would just jacked up on math.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
A little math speed,
you know,
all that stuff is just,
just those accelerants,
any of those things that just they fuck
with your judgment.
I remember there was this,
I believe it was Gq.
I was reading this article about this
guy who was a lawyer and he was this
real successful lawyer and he got
involved somehow or another with a
client that was a meth dealer and so
then all of a sudden he starts getting
into the math business.
He just realized there's a lot of
fucking money in this.
Yes,
I guess he started doing meth and then
he started selling math and then one of
the things they say is when you do a lot
of Meth,
you start making like really poor
judgement calls.
You're like,
oh,
this is fine.
This is fine.
This is going to work.
So he started a stockpile and meth in
his fucking basement,
like just stank and like as he opened
the door to his basement,
like,
what the fuck is down?
They're just big paint buckets filled
with math everywhere and that that can
burn your body.
It'll like jack you up.
If you put it on your skin,
it will burn through it within an hour.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why those guys have those day
touch it when they cut it up and then
they touch their face and that's how
they get those holes in their face.
I thought they started itching,
like they would start scratching
themselves right now it's the touch and
then the touch becomes the crater of the
pimple.
Then they start picking up that.
I had a buddy he'd walk around with like
bandaids everywhere.
Oh Man.
I was like,
fuck dude,
you need to chill.
So this girl was all hopped up on
Craig's mom,
the girl when you were 20.
Yup.
And then,
but back then I belong to a gang and
like every gang has their hustle.
Some gangs sell whack,
some gangs sells weed,
some gangs sell guns.
Ars was speed.
That was our hustle.
Somebody was fucking somebody that could
have got it.
And we got it.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was,
it was weird because this is like 1998.
So we're,
I remember we drove like a.
You remember when the Thunderbird,
the Ford car was cool.
Yeah,
the new one.
Right?
But it was in 1998.
Yeah.
I remember we had one,
we were just like,
yeah,
those were dope itches from the eight
one eight
and yeah,
it was fucking fun.
You know what's weird about speed is?
Well,
when I was in prison,
you could tell that these people are
still tweakers because you know how you
light a lighter,
your thumb goes down and then when you
hit the pipe you spin your finger in
this way,
so that's how you're hitting a speakpipe
because you're spinning it.
And I used to play handball with this
guy and he would do it every fucking
time.
He would just spin this hand and like,
like the lighter,
oh,
like make the movements and his fingers
while was playing hamlet.
Hey Dog,
you do like we call it bomb.
Hey,
you do bomb.
He's like,
well you got some.
I've been done two years.
I was like,
we used to make fun of him.
Like,
Hey,
don't hit the pipe,
serve the ball.
So for two years later he's still making
those motions.
It's your body craves it.
You can see it in people.
Their body is dislike.
I need that motion.
You'll notice when you see people doing
the spinning with the lighter,
they're tweakers.
Wow.
That's something I discovered.
You noticed it.
Yeah.
Recognition.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Well,
it's amazing that two years out he was
still wanting to know in prison.
Two years out of it.
Yeah.
Oh,
feening it.
Wow.
Feening couldn't wait.
Oh,
so that's a guy that just can't get it.
It's not like he's gotten sober.
He just can't get it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those guys.
I mean like there's a lot of people that
when they go to prison,
they're not druggies because to be a
druggie and prison is to be looked
frowned upon.
So you're a man in there and when you're
in there you're like,
fuck that.
I'm going to work out,
I'm going to be strong.
And then when you get out it's
temptation.
You're good looking,
you're healthy again.
You're getting it.
That's the weird part of prison.
So most of the guys.
So when,
when a guy's a junkie and he goes into
prison,
did they try to clean up or they try to
get it while you have to clean up?
Because if you don't clean up,
they're going to call you a Jay cat.
A Jay cat is like equivalent of a bomb,
but in prison,
if you're a Jay cat,
you're going to get picked on.
People are going to laugh at you.
You don't want to like,
you want to be clean and healthy.
Really?
Yes.
That's interesting because that's
contrary to what a lot of people would
think about prison.
They would think,
you know,
you go to prison,
you gave up hope and now you just let
yourself go.
And I mean that's what you think because
you're out there,
but when you're in there,
you notice people look at you and you
want people to like ice look at falls on
drugs and be like,
this fucking dude.
All right.
Yeah.
Here's the soap.
I know you don't got money because
you're wasting it on everything.
Here's a soup.
I wanted to be that guy that was just,
Oh,
look at,
you know,
homies clean.
He takes care of himself.
He's a man of his word and that's what
people want is when you get out,
it's there.
It's not like one of the bigger
misconceptions about prison,
like when you talk to people that
haven't been to prison that don't know
anything about prison,
what do you think?
Like the big misconceptions.
That big misconception is a.
do you get fucked in the ass?
You get raised the big one,
right?
Yeah.
And I'm like that shit is not even
allowed.
Like you'll get killed for that shit
because everyone's watching gangland and
they're watching us at lockup.
MSNBC.
Yeah.
And those are only protective custody of
yards.
They're never interviewing a real prison
yard where the shit's rules are rules.
That's it.
You don't make them,
you don't break them,
you follow them.
So like when you see that you ever
watched that thing was locked up the
they had that dude was the booty bandit.
See that one?
And I was like,
I was watching that.
I was like,
how much did that guy is like just
making shit up.
Yeah,
like the stories they used to make up.
This guy used to tell me,
hey dog,
back in the days there was this black
guy in Corcoran and if you fucked up the
guards would throw you in his cell.
And they used to call him purple passion
and they said he used to rip falls
apart.
And I was like,
what Gfe Fuck.
And my head,
I was like,
I will,
I'll bite him,
I'll do whatever.
No,
you're at.
No.
Yeah.
And that's.
And the other thing is,
is um,
that we work all
day and we break rocks and shit.
Yes.
No,
like,
let me give you the same in your Sally's
and uh,
usually have a job.
That job gives you 13 to thirty eight
cents an hour.
I was a butcher so I had the highest
paying job.
You would,
you would have been a butcher too.
So we would get up at 4:00,
take a shower,
clean our room,
clean ourselves,
we'd go to work,
come back,
then eat with our people quarter yard,
fuck around for a little bit,
trying to find a cigarette or something.
Go back to yard and then boom,
come back to the cell.
And like,
that's it,
it's like,
it's like a program,
another life.
There's,
I took college courses in there.
Uh,
I was a janitor.
I was,
it's fucking crazy.
I can just sit back and be like,
fuck man.
Sometimes I miss it.
I'm just saying I wish I was on the yard
working out with these guys and playing
basketball because the camaraderie of
like,
oh,
it was just awesome.
That's so crazy.
So it was fun sometimes.
Fuck yeah,
fuck yeah,
it was fun until like 12:00 hit or 9:00
hit.
And I'm like,
fuck,
I want to go do a spot.
Give me the fuck Outta here.
Right.
And then I'm just like,
I can't go home.
And then my last prison,
there was a park like 50 yards away from
us.
And you're just looking out the window.
Like,
fuck,
I want to go play the catch.
Yeah.
So there was moments.
It was fun.
But ultimately the big thing is the lack
of freedom.
You can,
you can have fun while you're there,
but you can't choose what you can do.
Yeah.
Lack of freedom and then you know,
prison cops are completely different
from cops on the street.
They're called correction officers and
in there there's a respect like when
they see you,
hey,
good morning,
how you doing today?
Everybody gets a good morning and if you
know,
if you're fucking up his program to make
them go out of his way,
it's your fault.
But if he wants to be tested then you
got to do what you gotta do.
If he wants to be tested.
Like how,
like,
you know,
there's these cops that go in there and
they,
they've had a problem.
You know,
I,
I could see why racism exist in prison
because maybe there's this cop that came
from Solidad and now he's going to
another prison.
And when he held,
the reason you left solid dad is because
all the Mexicans jumped his ass.
So he's going to have a little like,
hmm.
All right motherfuckers,
you got me over there?
Yeah,
it's weird.
They transfer them like that and then
like if you don't jump in,
I've seen cops talk shit on other cops.
Like all fuck that fool.
There's a ride.
He didn't do shit.
Oh really?
So it looks a lot like prisoners in some
way.
Yeah,
they are too,
because they're there 18 hours a day or
12.
They mean they just get to go home.
They do that long as shift.
Yeah,
it's a 12 hour shift.
Why?
They do such a long shift.
That's their union and they get a lot of
hours,
but they only work four days
a week.
Okay.
That's probably better.
I'd probably rather work 12 hours a day,
four days a week than eight hours a day
and five day and Kevin a whole extra day
to do whatever the fuck you want to do
because you feel like your day's kind of
wrecked anyway when you work eight
hours.
It's hard to get anything in.
I used to be a construction worker
before this and I hated that shit.
Before comedy,
I did construction when I was a kid.
My my stepfather was an architect,
so I got a lot of jobs on USS Cole
construction sites and I just remember
being exhausted.
That was the thing that I remember most.
Was it like residential housing tracks?
Most of it was residential,
but occasionally we would do like we did
a knights of Columbus Hall,
but that was,
I was working with my friend Jimmy and
his,
uh,
his boss.
It was a different construction company,
but that was the hardest job I've ever
had in my life because all I did the
whole summer was a.
I only,
I only survived for a couple of weeks.
I quit.
I was like,
I can't do this anymore.
I was carrying cement bags and pressure,
treated lumber all day.
I was 19 that I remember.
I remember thinking that was so
motivating because I was thinking like,
this is not gonna work.
Like I can't do this for my life.
I had no,
I was 19.
You're at the peak of your energy,
you know,
and I was.
And it was in the summer so it was hot,
you know,
as Boston.
So it was muggy bald.
No,
he didn't have a shaved head or no,
no,
not back then.
Okay.
Because the sun beats you're out.
Yeah.
Not a beautiful head of hair back then.
How's was lovely.
But I'm all day carrying bags of cement
and pressure treated lumber,
which is heavy as fuck.
So.
And then you'd get these splinters in
your hand.
They get all infected because the
pressure treated lumber has some sort of
chemicals in it.
Yeah.
It has like a something.
So the board doesn't bend because the
board bends with the sun.
Yeah.
It was brutal.
But I remember thinking this is a good
lesson because now because I used to
think God just get a good job,
work all day.
Then after work I'll do whatever the
fuck I want to do.
But I remember thinking,
nope,
that's not going to work.
You're not going to have any fucking
energy.
You're not gonna have any energy.
Yeah.
I used to be a cement finisher.
That was some shit we used to do curb
and gutter,
but we do it out of a machine.
You've ever seen those current machines?
Yeah,
it was a good Maaco remember at $1,500
we used to poor 40 fucking trucks a day.
Whoa.
And I used to like,
it was weird,
like my boss would look at me like if I
was like a Mexican that he didn't know I
was a citizen,
so I'd be like,
hey,
dog were pouring 40 trucks and they were
pouring 20,
why are they making as much money as us?
And He'd be like,
let's go back over there and get out of
here.
And I'd be like,
Hey,
I'm a fucking citizen dog.
My name starts with a g,
like come on.
We were union.
So it was,
yeah,
I got out of it.
Yeah.
That's the thing about California in
general that a lot of people don't
realize the massive amount of illegal
aliens.
It's straight up laugh when they,
when they say,
well,
there's 18 million people in the greater
Los Angeles area.
I'm like,
plus Mexicans.
Yeah.
Try to try to do the calculation.
You don't know what that number is.
Nobody knows.
It's a total guess.
That would be like the guests have
guesses.
Yeah.
How the fuck did they know?
That should be the lottery.
If you can guess how many illegal
immigrants are in,
you win the lottery.
Yeah,
you get a dollar for everyone.
It'll be insane.
Yeah.
This is probably,
I don't know,
I mean I would,
I would just guess it would be millions,
right?
Has to be this way more here and that's
just Mexicans or you're missing
Russians,
El Salvadorians,
Canadians,
Canadian lot of illegal Canadians
because they blend right the fuck in
until they say about you have no idea.
And they're like a boat and they're
like,
what?
We got one,
we found them.
How long were you in prison for?
I did three years,
uh,
two years.
Eleven months.
So they just shade three.
Tell me the story about it because you
were telling me that the comedy store,
it's kind of a fucked up story.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
before I was comedian,
I was a gangster and a deconstruction
and then uh,
I used to play sports so I was real good
in basketball and I was playing at the
park and you know,
basketball is a sport that's very
physical,
you know,
when you back someone in at the park,
there's no ref.
So it's full of men and trying to muscle
me.
So I'm like,
all right,
I go around them and I still a ball and
it's all foul.
Alright,
here you go,
take it.
So now me and him get physical and the
elbows me and I had to check myself like
hold up like you're in mice.
This is how I used to think back.
Then Joe,
I'm like,
you're in my city.
I got jumped into my gang at this park,
how am I going to let you elbow me?
So I socked him and we went at it and I
beat his ass bad.
Like you ever fight someone and like
they don't stop.
You know what I mean?
Like I mean I'm sorry,
like a lot of people look at me,
they're like,
no,
I've never had that problem.
I like this guy wanted to kick my ass
but I like,
I didn't want to hurt him so I just
dropped them and I throw them to the
floor.
Need a mug him.
Yeah man,
there's a,
there's some people that won't fucking
quit John if you're beating her ass.
Yeah.
So those people are dangerous.
Fuck yeah.
So I,
this is the funny part is I left him,
like I beat his ass and ran to my car.
I was like,
I need to go so I could
get to my car and I take off.
All right,
cool.
I see.
I,
I become a comedian maybe like a year
and a half later I become a comic
trying,
you know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
everyone says,
well I'm a comic.
I've gone up four or five times.
Like,
you know,
I'm trying to be a comic and a,
I get the,
I get a good break.
Jeff Garcia,
good guy,
man picked me up.
He goes,
hey,
you're my new opener.
Like fuck.
All right.
So I was like four months in the comedy
and I'm doing the Improv.
Not even knowing.
I'm just like talking to the crowd and
what's going on.
Like I'm probably like the best salesman
making people laugh.
That's all I'm doing now.
I don't even know jokes yet.
I'm trying them.
Then I get jokes and then uh,
I'm good at roasting and MTV,
your Mama comes out and I get picked up
for that show and I win my first
episode.
Fucking guy that I beat up sees me on TV
and he's like,
oh,
she had cash money.
This whole God's money.
So this is the crazy part is a lot of
people say,
oh,
there's a statute of limitations and all
that.
Since it's a John Doe crime,
it doesn't have it.
If you don't know who beats you up,
you don't have a limited restrictions.
So until they find out who beat you up,
then the statute of limitations case in,
I don't even know.
That's how horrible my lawyer was.
Wow.
That seems crazy.
So if you beat somebody up 50 years ago
and they just found out your name,
they could,
they could still sue you or take you to
jail.
I don't.
Yeah,
I mean I think it's,
I don't know,
probably like five.
So what year is this when this is all
going on?
Two thousand four.
2,000?
No,
this is 2000.
Two,
2003 because I fought it for two years
because my brother bailed me out.
I was still filming an MTV.
Wow.
So my brother bells me out.
He's like,
all right,
check the song,
got me a lawyer and all the crap.
Ah,
Shit.
I remember just going to court who?
Just that whole like,
what the hell is going on?
I stopped.
I'm not you.
They offered me eight years.
They're like,
look at it,
take eight years because he has a great
bodily injury.
This guy that I beat up,
he has a metal plate and he's all fucked
up and they're like,
take eight years.
And I was like a metal plate in his
cheek.
Yeah,
right here.
Orbital fracture.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I see a lot of those.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I mean I caught them good.
Like I think I caught them like just,
you know,
all this stuff around the eyes breaks
pretty easy.
All this stuff.
Okay.
Orbital stuff.
It's super common in mma especially.
It was weird because they were trying to
say I used a weapon.
They're like,
there's no way you could have done that.
And I was like,
oh,
he's crazy.
Yeah.
I was like,
I didn't use a weapon.
So I bail out.
I'm doing a comic.
Being a dad,
I think I'm going to win this case.
That's the funny part.
Because I was like,
dude,
nobody was there.
Nobody seen me.
But then I have to admit that you beat
him up.
No.
See I couldn't even take the stand
because I already knew if I take the
stand that makes me look like a snitch
and I'm not going to go into prison.
So if you take the stand and talk about
the fight and makes you look like a
snitch.
Yeah.
Because you're like,
he started it.
He did it.
It's just the,
you know,
it's the politics of I had to accept the
fact where I was coming from and it was
the punishment that was like when I
started realizing in my head like,
alright dog,
you chose this,
now you have to accept this.
You're not going to be one of those
guys.
This is,
oh,
rats and mountain.
You get away with it.
No.
So I didn't take the stand and they're
last.
Wow.
Well if you did take the stand,
well,
what could you possibly have said you,
you,
I think I would have incriminated myself
because I,
I mean in my head I remember like
fuck,
you've never been to court so when you
go to court,
like they assign a jury and when you go
they give you like a lunch break and you
go eat my stupid ass when and ate like
where the jury was eating and I could
tell the way they're looking at me
because I'm in a suit and I go to Burger
King,
I take my suit off.
I'm like fuck this,
I'm all tatted up now.
Like look at this guy,
right?
Like they just threw judgment on me and
I remember my brother telling me,
you looked like you had no remorse.
You were in there laughing and court and
I was just like,
fuck.
I didn't know.
You know what I mean?
Like fuck it.
It's court cases.
I would imagine it would be so difficult
to because no one wants to do fucking
jury duty.
I got my friend Andreas Antonopoulos was
here the other day,
was talking about how he got out of jury
duty by just explaining how much he
knows about the judicial system,
how corrupt he thinks it is and how
fucked up he thinks it is.
And they were like,
get outta here out.
Nobody wants to do jury duty.
If you like your job and you do
something that you enjoy now you're
going to spend eight hours a day,
you know,
trying to deliberate and figure out why
people make such quick judgements.
I think it's a terrible way to decide
whether or not someone's guilty or
innocent.
Yeah,
you're exactly right.
And it's weird because like the jury,
like,
I think they wanted it.
It was a weird,
it was like an ex cop and I was like,
why did you let this ex cop get on the
panel?
I'm already guilty because of my look.
Right,
right.
You know,
it's like imagine if these cops that are
shooting people the whole panels.
Prisoners.
Yeah.
That'd be hilarious.
You know what I mean?
A good luck
saw.
Yes.
So Alright Joe,
check this out.
So now I'm out,
I think I'm gonna win it.
Boom.
Joey Diaz calls me up.
Hey,
we're going to do showtime comedy slam.
I was like,
what the fuck?
He gets me off my ass all comedy slim.
So I,
I get on showtime.
Uh,
I did a comedy central.
I did like a sketch comedy and then I go
to court bone.
I lose
it wouldn't usually when you lose they
let you go home.
All right,
I'll come back.
But since I was a high risk inmate now
they took me right there,
like from court in a suit straight to
the holding tank.
Who?
Yeah,
that was a shock.
Oh.
And my showtime hasn't even come out
yet.
I hadn't even seen this thing.
So it's like everything I've worked for
got took.
That's why I looked at it at that time.
I won't forget that day I walked down
there,
I had his fucking suit on.
I've ever everybody looking at me like,
damn,
this was a baller.
I was like,
Nah,
I just lost my case.
I wasn't on the street.
And then from there you go to the county
because now they got to give you a
sentencing.
The judge has to come up with a
sentence.
You kind of familiar with this.
So
a month in the county jail,
a riot breaks out.
Now I have to involve myself.
I know where I'm at,
I know what's going on.
So now they put me in the hole and I got
to go to court to get sentenced.
So you have to involve yourself.
Meaning you have to pick a side,
you have to fight.
Yeah.
What's the,
what's the right about A.
I don't know,
I just seen my people fighting other
people on the uterus.
You don't ask questions,
there's no questions to be asked.
And let me and let me give you a picture
of what's going on.
It's a,
it's like a huge fuck.
Yeah.
It's kind of like a,
it's on msnbc where they got all the
cells on top and on the bottom.
And then there's like a,
we call it the bubble where the police
are,
it's a big bubble.
And uh,
there was a riot happening like all on
the whole other side,
so we had to run down there and then
they come in and they shoot you with a
paintball guns.
But they have like peppermints not
pepper pepper spraying them and they're
shooting you a paintball guns,
pepper spray block guns,
rubber band.
All that Shit's flying off in there and
you're trying to run back to your bunk.
The only way to get out of a riot is to
show they look at everybody's hands and
they say,
Hey,
know your hands are marked.
Your any mark you have,
you're going to the hole.
So if you have marks on your hands and
indicate that you punched somebody.
Yes.
Even if you got punched.
Yeah you don't.
I don't.
You don't do that in there now it gets
crazy,
man.
Like some people will throw hot water on
you.
Whoo.
Yeah.
It's,
it's all out for everybody.
This is just the county.
And did you ever find out what the ride
was about?
No,
I didn't.
You don't,
you don't ask questions.
The more questions you ask,
the more people will want to.
Oh you want to find out who did.
All right Mr. investigator,
come on,
we got something for you.
So I just,
I stayed quiet.
No.
Alright.
And if you know,
I was just like,
Hey,
I was there because he just knew what,
what you had to do.
You knew what your role had to be in
order to stay safe.
Yeah,
dude,
I've heard other stories from other
inmates that are like,
yeah,
dog.
I went to Chino and there's a riot going
on and I told myself,
fuck,
if I don't get in this I'm going to have
to pay.
He's like,
I just ran and I jumped into it and he
got stabbed.
Wow.
Yeah.
But he goes,
Hey doc,
I got my stripes and I was that wow,
what is the stripe?
What do you mean by stripes?
Stripes is Kinda like a saying like,
you know,
the homies down disguise down every.
I don't know how other races do it,
but like,
you know,
it's like,
Hey,
I've been with this foreigner yard.
He's down for his,
you know,
because you want to be by someone that
you're in there to protect your life.
So you want to be with people like that.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
you're trying to go home and better
yourself,
but at the end of the day,
no.
So on a lot of ways,
like with a riot,
you want someone that's like a soldier.
You want a soda,
a soldier,
you don't want a soldier going asking
the sergeant a sergeant,
what is the plant?
Why are we doing this?
Do we know who these people are?
What did they do to us?
Is this right for hr?
You know you want sir?
Yes sir.
That's what you want.
You want someone who's just going to go,
but in there it's just,
you know,
any little disrespect and triggered and
start anything and you just have to
follow suit.
Like if you're my celly and the cop
pushes or punches you,
I have to jump in for you no matter.
Even if I'm going home that day or the
next day it goes down.
You have to.
It's just what it is.
So the riot breaks out,
you get involved in riot,
you get thrown in the hole and then what
happens is I'm in the hall and the whole
fucking horrible.
I get staff on my fucking ass on the
side because they only gave me one bar
soap and I was in there for 28 days and
then I remember I was cleaning my toilet
with it in my room with the soap and
then I ran out.
So I was just taking showers with water
and then I noticed I had like an ingrown
hair on the side and it just got
infected.
So that's how it starts for us.
Yeah.
And it's crazy because there's a little,
there's a little button you can push,
like if you're dying.
And I had like A.
I had a fever and I've ever pushed the
button until the car at.
Amen.
I know it's night shift and I don't want
to bug you [inaudible] man.
But my.
I didn't say I got my ass is bleeding,
but I was like [inaudible],
you have to have a.
At the sight of my ass is bleeding.
So you're gonna need to call Yvette
Yvette,
you're going to have you to call
somebody and he just like stopped
playing games.
I'm like,
and they have cameras in there.
I was like look.
So I showed them and then they come in
and you got to put your arms in there
because they're gonna be a plant.
I don't know.
They're scared for their life.
So he handcuffed me or then that gets
taken care of and then I go to
court and I get sentenced to three
years.
So do you think it would have been less
if it wasn't for the riot?
No,
the,
the riot was,
it was cool because at that time when it
was going on,
there was riots breaking out everywhere.
And my lawyer was like,
listen,
your honor,
he was only in a riot to have to protect
his life.
You know,
how you don't know what's going on in
there.
And the judge was cool.
A lot of my family and friends wrote
letters for me telling the judge,
hey man,
this guy changed his life.
He's got the best peanut butter math you
can get hands on.
So that amount of hooky up.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So you know,
cause a Gbi it's a great bodily injury.
That's a felony that carries a three
year,
like on top of your time.
It's like supposed to and goes,
I'm gonna.
Strike that down.
And I was just like Oh my God.
And in my head I'm thinking,
oh you only do half time.
So I'm gonna get out year and a half
because he even told me you're doing
good guy,
but somebody got hurt.
And I was like,
all right.
So boom.
I hit Wasco while skulls or reception
yard where like if you're from Orange
County,
la,
Bakersfield,
and I think some part of Riverside they
send you to that yard for reception.
It's where you for 90 days you're on
lockdown,
23 hour lockdown and you only get like
an hour of day room and they're
evaluating you to see how you act with
other inmates.
Where are they going to put you?
Or they're going to put you on a level
four yard.
A level three yard.
I love a two yard.
Yeah.
Do you don't want to level four?
Level three,
two is now give me the difference.
A level four yard is for people that um,
have a lot of points like violent crime.
Like,
oh,
he's in here for carjacking kidnapping
on all that.
You're going on to level four yard.
You're going to be on a 23 hour lockdown
and you're there with killers.
Lifers,
people doing 10 to 15 to 20 years.
A level three yard is the same thing,
but your programming,
you're getting your own.
It goes down,
it goes down,
but it's chill.
Then there's a level two yard where it's
like,
all right,
this guy got three years left,
you know,
we try to get them an outside job,
a little more money and then level one
yard is like,
go walk around in sandals.
I've heard,
I've never been on that.
I heard you go walk around in sandals.
There's a microwave in the day room has
an ice machine.
So what does that for like white collar
crime?
No,
a level one yard would be like,
this guy's been locked up for 10 years
on drugs.
He's going home.
He's done all nine years.
One year left permanent level one yard
because he's proven he can program as
long as you're not causing problems.
The point system makes you drop.
I think it's from one to 17 is level one
yard and 17 to 32 is a level two yard
and 32 to 40 something or is a level
three.
Then it goes far enough up to life.
Yeah.
Like I,
I knew buddies that were like a dog.
How many points you got to go?
I'm lucky I'm going to like,
I was.
They sent me to a level two yard after I
was on a three yard.
Now he was like,
oh my God.
Like these inmates treated like you're
going to a level two.
Oh my God.
Cause they're like,
you're going to.
You can have a TV in your cell.
It's like it's.
Yeah,
it's like a heaven.
Wow.
Yeah.
The food's better.
Oh Man.
So much shit about prison.
I,
I miss food now in there.
You miss food in prison.
What kind of food did you get in prison?
We used to make food spreads and I
worked in the butcher shop so I would
sneak meat in my socks.
I'd wrap it up and like,
like Saran wrap and I'd put it in my
boots and this boot I had big old
firemen,
boots and I would fit to like two
sandwiches in each booth.
And that's like eight bucks in prison.
That's fucking nuts.
Money,
especially if you're making thirty eight
cents an hour.
So we'd bring it back.
This time I'm living in a dorm hundred
man dorm and we will bring it back and
me and all my friends,
my people,
we'd cut it up.
Everyone would have a job.
I already dog,
I ain't got nothing to pitch in but I'll
prepare the food and I'll,
I'll clean all the dishes are done.
All right,
cool.
Everybody will contribute and then we'd
make like our bunk is equivalent from
here to that chair and we would eat on a
bunk.
We put like a big piece of paper and we
would just,
it'd be cup of noodles to retos slim
jims cheese.
Uh,
says ship pork grinds,
beans,
rice,
corn,
nuts.
Anything that we had and we were just
mixing in that's done.
And did anybody ever like,
uh,
the,
like the prison guards ever come by and
get you get in trouble for this checking
on you?
Oh,
that's routine.
They know what we're doing.
So they don't have a problem with it and
they don't.
As long as what I noticed in prison,
they just don't want no one to overdose
or fight.
Yeah.
I remember this one guy,
like,
we're not a lot of talk to guards.
I could hear them talking to each other.
This one guy goes,
man,
I hate my job.
I'm the fucking most overpriced
babysitter in the world.
All I have to do is make sure these guys
don't kill each other and they're
hitting here for killing each other.
Fuck.
Yeah.
So yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
And what did you cook it on?
Oh,
that,
that's a good idea.
I mean,
good question.
So,
uh,
we get this thing called a stinger,
like there's so many brilliant like
inventions people make in prison.
This guy would get a cord for the radio,
cut it in half,
get a metal piece and connect like some
we'd make like this thing and then you
plug it into the wall,
drop it into like a five gallon water
bucket,
like those buckets.
And then we put all the food in a
plastic bags so the water wouldn't hit
it,
but it would steam cook it.
That's how we would cook.
Whoa.
There was even by size that can make
grills like because there's a metal shop
in there,
like you work metal
us as prisoners,
like the prison doesn't call plumbing to
fix the prison.
We have our own plumbing crews,
like inmates are plumbers,
inmates are everything.
So we learned to fix all this stuff and
you know when it's there you're like
damn,
I want to make a grilled cheese
sandwich.
So where we were at,
they had those heaters that are metal
and you get your bread and you put it in
the Brown bag and you just put it in
there and 20 minutes later to Melton and
it is a grilled cheese.
Wow.
What is the fine art of cooking in
prison?
What is this champion?
Just trying to find out the Stinger.
I found a couple of pictures,
but this is a better picture of.
Oh,
okay.
So he's got wires attached to toenail
clippers.
That's another way to.
And the toenail clippers get get hot
electrified and they boiled the ramen
noodles.
The Stinger is the one on the far left.
That one right there.
You see how it's in there and that's how
we did it,
but we did it with the five gallon.
Wow.
Yeah.
There was this guy that he would put
loud.
Lowery's is addressing right sauce.
Yeah.
He would pick a spice route.
He would get the spice and he would put
water in it and he would plug it into
the fucking wall for somehow and this
little spring,
like spring with light up like and
that's isolated cigarettes.
He's like,
whoa.
Yeah.
And I'd be like,
this fool man.
A lighter
where they make their own tattoo guns
too.
That's all my tattoos are.
Eighty percent of my tattoos are from
prison.
Wow.
Now is that legal in prison?
No,
no,
because that's how you get infections
before.
That's the other big thing.
Uh,
what's that thing called
A.
I don't know.
Somebody has it,
but yeah.
But I love my tattoos.
Like hepatitis.
Yeah.
Hepatitis is huge because everyone's
sharing needles,
but no one does that really.
Like you get your own needle and you
take care of it.
Like I have my,
I've used my same needle the whole three
years.
I was there.
Your same tattoo needle and did you make
it?
Yeah,
you get a
guitar string is what they use,
but that's huge.
Like you see how this is way thicker.
That's the guitar string and not hurt
and this is more of like we use like the
wire because wire brush on the brooms so
we just take the little things off and
sharpen them up,
sanitize it.
Wow.
And how are they using the.
Like how are they doing a tattoo?
Like what is tapping the ink in it?
They're doing it by hand.
I know there's a,
you get a,
a motor from a Walkman or like a Walkman
in prison tapes and cds or there's no
fucking downloads in there.
Joe,
you can't
cassette tape because that same presence
to.
I used to have the beastie boys and I
sold that.
I gave it to my boy and I laughed.
Like,
hey man,
it's it.
It's kind of like fucking being locked
up in American pickers,
like old technologies existing hardcore
in prison.
Wow.
And so Walkman,
if the Walkman messes up,
they take the motor out and then they
make it like there's just like the shop,
they got a little gas pedal.
Like they just wire it up.
Yeah,
there it is.
Exactly.
What is that?
That looks like an ink pen while it's a
pencil.
And then he's just that right there is
the motor in the back.
That's the motor for it.
It's a button.
So the button attaches to the motor?
Yes.
And is a string on that.
So it goes up and down.
So forces the needle to go up and I'll
sit here,
goes drive pin on top of the motor turns
the spindle.
The spindle causes the connecting pin to
rotate as the back end of the draw of
the drive rod rotates with the pin,
the needle moves backwards and forwards.
Wow.
And you have to make your own ink.
So what are you doing for ink?
So you get the newspaper and you burn it
in a brown bag.
You just let it burn in the sun.
The ink from the paper is becomes ashes
and you get all these ashes and you put
it in like a like this or like a little
like advil or like a little aspirin
thing and he put two little rocks in
there at three and then a little bit of
water and shake that shit for three or
four days and it will become the ink
again.
Three or four days.
Yeah,
it's a long process.
I had to figure out how you got.
You got all day,
you get plenty of time.
Yeah.
I mean you don't do it for 24 hours,
you just come back.
That is it,
that it's it.
Cause I've had tattoos that fall off
like the ink on this one.
It wasn't done right.
I see,
and it's faded off because they didn't
let it sit in the.
Exactly.
Wow.
So all those,
like the stomach one,
all that shit is all dad.
The stomach one.
I'll never forget.
Painful.
Huh?
Fuck.
At that time it was painful.
Is the gooners came in and hit the house
like the gooners?
Yeah,
I remember I was telling you in,
in prison they have a swat team to.
It's called the gooners.
These are ceos that specialize in gang.
Any gang activity,
any riot,
anybody has contraband.
Like they just come in and raid the
whole yard.
Like,
do you know what I mean?
like throwing mattresses everywhere.
Ripping shit up.
So I'm getting this tattoo on my stomach
and they come in and I'll catch you in
the middle again.
No,
I hit it.
You hit it.
Covered my shit up.
My friend,
he cheeked it.
He,
you see how little they shooked yeah.
He took the uh,
the pink top off and just do it in the
trash and then you put the motor up.
Not up his ass but like in the ass,
like cheeked it.
He put it a Napkin and uh,
I was,
I just remember he was like,
hey man,
I don't think I'm going to be able to
come tomorrow.
So do you want to finish this?
Like,
let's go dog.
We just sanitized it.
Wow.
Yeah,
we stole Lysol.
I mean we didn't steal it.
It's ours.
It's the prisons that we just,
we took it and that wasn't a little
thing.
They don't let you have lysol wipes it
out because it worried you spray it on.
People are like on fire.
It's like things you light lights on
fire and spray people.
Okay.
Yeah.
But it's Kinda like,
do you know how much diseases and Shit
isn't there?
I would imagine quite a bit.
And was chicken tattoo machines and
that's how sound theory.
That's crazy.
So if you had gotten caught like getting
the Tattoo,
like what would happen?
So if you get caught now,
I think they give you a 1:15 now.
One 15 can make you get bad points.
So like say I'm on a level two yard and
I get caught getting tatted.
They're like,
hey homie,
you,
we don't want this here.
That's for the crazier yard,
so they ship you over there.
Wow.
Just for a tattoo.
Yeah,
because to them you're.
You've hurt your body,
but it's hilarious.
Yeah.
There's some good tattoo artist in
prison though.
I've seen some great work that came out
of prison.
There's some bomb ass guys in there.
Yeah.
There's some websites that are dedicated
to great tattoo art from prison CV.
Find some of that,
but some of those guys are like legit
artists,
like as good or close to it as like Mr.
Cartoon.
Like that level.
I've seen some like high level.
I've seen some.
Yeah.
I mean I'm pretty sure Mr. cartoon
rumors are.
I Dunno,
I won't call it,
but I know artists that do their friends
are doing life in prison and they send
them patterns like that.
Yeah.
That is from fucking jail.
That's amazing.
And that's not when no shop.
You can't Google expand.
None of that.
Damn.
Look how good that is.
That's a.
it's.
That's a Tom Hardy,
right?
The one on the left from.
From Brian Charles Bronson,
right?
It's from Bronson,
the movie Bronson.
Yeah.
I love that movie.
It was about a crazy prisoner.
He was off.
I think he's from England.
Yeah.
Have you seen that movie?
Long time ago though.
I hardly remember it,
but I remember he still locked up.
That guy is really 40 years in solitary
confinement now.
Whoa.
Four zero.
That can't be good.
No,
no.
That's not good.
Tattoo artists praises Charles Bronson.
Oh,
it is Charles Bronson Bronson the movie.
The guy's name is Charles Charles
Bronson award winning tattoo by the
prisoner himself.
Oh,
wait a minute,
Jamie.
That's not.
That's not a prison tattoo.
Then seed sent.
Tattoo artists praised for Charles
Bronson award winning tattoo by the
prisoner.
Charles Bronson.
I was saying that.
Let me give you a better code words when
you Google Prison Tattoos,
a r t,
e
d e prison all over his face.
That seems like a weird choice.
Oh Man.
I see those all day in there.
Yeah.
That's an odd choice.
Is that now is that dudes that are just
doing life and I'm like,
yeah,
I mean,
yeah.
I mean at the same time,
man,
there's a lot of people in there that
are.
That's all they know.
Dad Has it,
mom has it,
and when he has it and I was their
soldiers right there.
That's this letting you know it's going
down.
Do not walk this way.
It goes down.
Well,
if you're willing to do that to your
face,
you don't have a whole lot to lose the
face tattoos.
A rough man.
That's.
That's a strange look.
Is that.
No,
because you can't get no color in
prison.
You can't.
No.
It'd be too hard to make unless,
I mean,
I don't know if they sneak enemy the
sneaking print.
Pretty much anything,
right?
I don't think.
No.
I was trying to sneak in tattoo tattoo
ink for that risk.
Maybe you would if you knew the dude was
just so fucking good.
Like if you got.
If you were doing time with a dude who
was a known tattoo,
artists like,
I'm Aaron Dellavedova is got to do all
my work in San Diego.
If I was locked up with that dude,
I tried to sneak some tattoo ink in.
Fuck the lead.
Let's go to work.
Let's get some shit done.
I mean see that.
That would be his hustle on there,
so I'm pretty sure if he's that good,
he'd come around and get people to make
it.
Lots of people's Hustle.
That's all they do.
Like for this tattoo,
I only paid a pack of cup of noodles.
Cup of noodles.
Now is that like what?
Like the.
Is that what currency is in prison?
Cigarettes.
Company noodles.
Well,
cigarettes isn't currency,
but it is because it's banded.
Used to be currency,
but it's flat now.
Yeah.
It's food in any material items like.
So you can't get any cigarettes in
prison at all.
It's not,
don't get them,
but it's not legal.
No.
Yeah.
Wow.
So if you are a cigarette person,
you smoked three packs of cigarettes a
day,
you go to jail.
Set Cold Turkey.
And that was the first time I stopped.
Oh yeah.
I didn't get a cigarette for the first
10 months.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then I had a sally that came from
Santa Barbara and Santa Barbara.
They let you have cigarettes in their
farming.
So homey snuck it.
I want to know.
I don't know how he did it,
but probably represent.
So when you're farming,
like you're out there farming in Santa
Barbara,
then you can have cigarettes?
Yeah,
because it's an outside facility.
Oh,
okay.
It's not in trapped in the building.
Oh,
okay.
So was the idea about smoking in the
building that you don't want people to
get secondhand smoke or something like
that?
Is that what it is?
I think that that's what they said.
This is 2000.
This happened in 2006,
2007.
So there laws might've changed.
It was interesting because when I first
moved here in 94,
you could still smoke in bars.
You could smoke everywhere,
everywhere had cigarettes.
I believe that comedy store had
cigarettes,
if I remember correctly,
I believe that ash trays on every table,
if I remember correctly.
Yeah,
yeah.
If I remember correctly,
I know a lot of clubs I worked at had
smoking until the two thousands.
Dallas was one of the last holdouts.
I used to do the Addison Improv and they
would still have smoking,
but they would have like.
Then they started having like an 8:00 PM
nonsmoking show,
toddlers.
But I didn't mind it,
you know.
And I know it's probably bad for you,
but then I started hearing about women
that would be like waitresses and bars
and they would work there for 15 years
now get lung cancer and it's like,
oh,
that's real.
That's real.
Yeah.
That's when I was like,
because I was
against it to like,
what the fuck?
I can't smoke because America.
Then you're like,
oh,
I'm fucking her up.
Sorry.
My bad.
Yeah.
So when you went away,
how hard was it to quit cigarettes?
Was that one of the hardest things to
do?
Ha.
Fuck.
I never thought of this.
But your mind,
I mean you're looking for,
you're at,
you're aggravated,
but Nah,
but you weren't doing this like the
tweakers spinning this thing when you're
met with the folks you're trying to do.
Did you go back to smoking when you got
out?
Yeah,
I had
because I was smoking in there.
You weren't.
I was getting them later because I had
that butcher job.
So I was trading meet for cigarettes all
day.
All Day.
Like a couple of cigarettes here and
there.
Fuck yeah.
Like how many kids you get a day?
Man,
I was living like a ball or joe realized
smoked a cigarette every day for at
least a year.
Wow.
That golf ball or one cigarette?
One cigarette.
Sometimes more.
And now one cigarette was like,
oh,
here comes,
ha.
No,
it was weird because make me want to
smoke.
I'm like,
I had a lighter too.
So when you have a lighter you can light
other people's cigarettes.
So you're like,
Hey,
your letter.
Like Nah,
Nah,
let me like that for you.
Here you go.
So yeah,
it was fun.
It was fun.
Stupid asking me.
Wow.
When do you smoke now?
Still?
Yeah,
I still smoke.
How much smoke?
I smoke about a Duh.
I say a pack a day,
but if I could I have a lot of things to
do.
A pack and a half.
Oh yeah.
But you know what?
I've dropped everything else.
No more peanut butter.
Meth?
No,
I haven't done that in ever.
Fuck that.
Like I don't do nothing else and I just,
I mean I smoked weed but that's,
that's it's Madison and what kind of
does what I'm saying?
I'm now what kind of like,
um,
weightlifting facilities do they have in
gyms because they are in prison?
Because I've heard some prisons,
they're trying to take that out.
They could makes presidents more
dangerous.
You know,
who took it out to?
It was Arnold Arnold was the one that
took out sugar.
That is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
The bodybuilding champion.
That guy took out the weights.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fucked up.
So that it's fucked up.
Yeah.
So like we have to improvise.
So when you're in prison,
you have jumpsuits and everyone was big
clothes.
So you cut the leg off your jumpsuit and
you sold the bottom and you sold the
sides and then you get the other leg and
you do the same thing and then you fill
it up with sand.
Now you have a heavy bag,
so it's probably like 40 pound bag and
then you put,
you just get a tailor guy in there or if
you know how to do it,
you can put two little handles and now
you can do curls or you can do for and
raises.
It's like what?
Anything water rates.
I mean we,
it's wild how he used to work out in
there.
Wow.
So when you were there and you were
working out,
there wasn't any weights?
No.
There's no way to allow loud at all
because you know,
how many people were,
how much people were killing each other
with weights?
Yeah.
Just imagine you owe money and you're
doing fucking bench press and somebody
just hit you with the 45 plate on the
head.
It's a one hit.
But that was always the scenes in the
movies.
Manage weight room or a,
it looked dope.
I want it to do it.
Imagine it was all little benches.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But they do have them on level one
yards.
Really fire camp now.
They made it like a privilege.
Like if you're in fire camp,
fire camp,
fire camp is a,
all the inmates,
they uh,
make them go brush the fire follows me
all these huge fires.
Oh,
okay.
All the inmates are like,
they're fighting the fires and then
they,
they only do one third of their time.
That's awesome.
But you can't be a violent offender in
there.
So I was disqualified from that.
So they do that so that you could be
more robust physically so you can do the
job better.
Yeah.
And it's just like to privilege.
They don't live in cells.
They live like in a room like this.
Wow.
And they got bunks and they have like a
little white badge,
crowbar.
But if anything happens immediately took
away.
So every race decides not to cut.
Ever happen here.
We need this for all of us.
So it's like a little like,
hey,
we need this.
Do not fuck this up.
Wow.
So what did you guys do for
entertainment when you're in there?
Oh Shit.
Did you do stand up in there at all?
Yeah,
I did later on.
That's a crazy question.
No one's ever asked me that.
That's what Joey got started,
you know?
Yeah.
But it was different because in my last,
my last year and a half,
I'm locked up in Norco.
So all these guards are Mexican.
Most of them that are Mexican and
they're like,
I used to fucking see you at wile
coyote.
They're like,
I just seen you on showtime.
And they,
like,
you're at the Ontario Improv,
so you know,
they got together and uh,
they were like a,
a,
you want to do comedy.
And I was just like,
fuck,
I did not want this.
I did not want like to be popular,
you know what I mean?
Like I didn't want him to stay low key.
Yeah.
Then I was just like a,
I don't know,
man,
like I'm offensive.
I'll say something that'll start a riot.
And they're like,
Nah,
Nah.
All the races already said you can say
whatever you want.
Like they planned this shit.
I was like,
all right,
I'll do it.
So all the races.
So you have to have like a little race
knowing.
Fuck yeah.
Hell yeah.
So how does that go down?
It's,
I don't know,
I wasn't involved in it,
it's just so they had to like meet with
maybe the guard went up to the white
rep,
the black wrap and all the reps was
like,
hey man,
check it out.
You guys.
We have a celebrity comedian here.
That's how they pumped me up.
I was like,
motherfucker can't even get a week at
the Improv,
but I could get a weakened prison.
That's a good one.
Thank you.
So,
uh,
it was,
it was.
Oh man,
it was weird.
I was scared as hell,
like,
no,
Mike and they put me in the TV room and
there was like 60 straight,
like fools,
like just like,
come on dog,
make us laugh.
And like,
you know,
they had never heard my jokes so I did
my whole set and they're just like,
oh.
And then I guess one of the cops,
this is the weird part is all the cops
left their dorms to come watch this
show.
And they went back and then they told
the inmates.
So when I go to yard the next day the
inmates were like,
hey dog,
how much you charge?
Come do a show in our room.
I was like,
what do you mean?
They're like,
I heard you did comedy.
And everybody said it was cool.
All the racist said you were cool.
And I was just like,
I don't think I can go to your dorm.
Did that's like against the code.
So the cops would be like,
all right everybody give him an item and
you can go in there and perform an item.
An item is like a soup,
a hot chocolate,
and that's how people paid to see.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it got to the point where I did
every,
everyone on,
on our yard and a half.
I assembled like a little crew.
I'm,
I taught this guy had to open for me
because he was cool as Druggie from
whittier.
He was just,
he was stupid,
funny,
taught him how to do standup and he knew
it but didn't know.
He knew it.
He knew it,
but he never did it Jack.
Because like,
I remember he'd be like a dog when I'm
on the street,
he has fucked up teeth.
It's like I called,
I called girls and I'm like,
they're like,
how's your body?
And he's like,
I just smiled like Chisel.
I was like,
oh,
that's a setup right there.
Like you're just,
he did it.
And uh,
the look on his face was cool man.
But I just remember he was like,
Hey dad,
I'm gonna hit you up when I get out,
we're going to go on the tour.
I'm like,
no,
you're a fucking tweaker.
Well,
it's fine because people that can make
people laugh.
If I always tell people,
like if you can make your friends laugh,
you can make people,
you know,
laugh.
It's entirely possible that you could be
a comedian.
It's the same thing.
It's just a matter of whether or not you
get these people to allow you inside
their head.
Yeah.
That's kind of what it is,
right?
Yeah.
The true comfortableness.
But you know,
some of them wasn't like I had a rough
time a couple first 10 minutes because
fools were like,
I thought you were going to do George
Lopez his jokes.
I was like,
no,
I'm not.
I'm,
I'm not an impersonator.
Like,
like fools were pissed.
They're like,
hey,
you didn't do any member members or
nothing like that.
Oh,
that's funny.
So they just thought,
stand up comedy is kind of like music.
Yeah.
Like he would just go up there and do
some hits.
Yeah,
they didn't know this is the crazy part
is uh,
the award and catches wind of this shit
and I'm in a program called sap,
it's substance abuse program and I'm
only in it because you qualify for
halftime if you take this program.
So the wardens like,
hey Sacramento's coming down here,
I want to show them a rehabilitated con,
criminal,
whatever.
I'm a felon,
So I was like,
what are you talking about?
He's like,
well,
you do comedy in front of the program
and Sacramento,
but no cussing.
Uh,
no.
Like I think this was the easiest deal
I've ever met.
I said,
look,
I'll do it if you bring me Kentucky
Fried Chicken
and Soda Joe.
I was just saying that the talk show,
you know how like when I first started
getting gigs,
I'd always call joy de is,
hey,
they're going to give me 700 if I go do
visalia,
like dumb ass,
I don't give it.
So after the show he gives me two,
two liters of coke and a fucking bucket
of Kentucky.
Oh Man.
And he was just like,
I remember walking back and everybody
was like,
I gave all my people a piece and it was
just like,
it was Kinda like a,
that movie,
Shawshank redemption when they're
drinking on the roof.
It was like the first time,
like we ate outside food.
Like I haven't had a soda in years.
So everybody was like,
get down home.
He was like,
oh,
it was cool.
Wow,
that's fucking cool.
There's something cool about
appreciating something that you,
you just take for granted because you
can get it anytime you want,
but when you're so restricted you get
those things.
And it's so good.
Yeah,
no dude,
they loved it.
They loved it.
And it was cool because like a lot of.
I mean dude,
I made friends.
Like there's guys I still talk to,
there's like friends.
And it was yeah,
it was awesome.
Like how can I say that?
How was prison?
Awesome.
But it was like when people say that
about war to men,
you know,
people say that about,
I think human beings need a certain
amount of struggle.
And then when you experienced that
struggle than the non struggle feel so
much better.
You know,
there's,
there's moments where I've talked about
this before,
but I,
when I'm hike,
oh,
and I'm hunting in Alaska on this
island,
Prince of Wales,
and it rained every day.
We were there for six days.
Pouring rain,
drenched her hunting.
Yeah.
It was the worst,
like as far as like getting wet and just
being soaked and cold all the time.
One of the worst experiences you could
ever go through because you're just,
it's always like 45,
50 degrees pouring rain and you know,
you're sleeping bags with the inside of
your tents.
Wet.
Everything's wet.
But when I came back,
I remember it was sunny out and I called
my friend Steve Rinella who,
uh,
took me with him on this trip I go to.
I've never been happier in my life.
Like the sun is shining like what I
normally just totally take for granted.
Exactly.
I was like,
it's amazing.
I love it.
I'm like,
I'm driving on the street.
Um,
so I don't think I've ever been happier,
but I was that happy because I had gone
through the struggle,
but nobody wants to do that on their
own,
you know,
and when you're kind of forced into a
situation I would imagine like being in
prison.
Then when you get that Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you get that soda,
you're like,
wow,
we're,
we're fucking live in it
now.
Yeah,
because I,
I,
I came from a place,
they have this thing,
it's called a fuck.
I forgot what it's called,
but you have money in your books.
Everybody has money and they do like a
sell off or they'll go to the local vons
by the prison and they'll buy.
You can buy sodas,
cookies and pizza.
But nobody ever had Kentucky Fried
Chicken in that bitch.
Like to this day,
that's like my,
I want to put that in my,
in my,
like my bio Hack Kentucky Fried Chicken
in prison in Kentucky Fried Chicken.
I don't know what they do,
but that is some special food.
They just know how to do it.
Those fucking crepes.
Kentucky Fried Chicken with Ellie.
You could take a hot sauce.
It's cold.
Especially God damn.
It's not.
No,
it's not good for you folks.
I don't eat a lot,
but it's a bad habit.
Guilty pleasure.
It's so good.
You know what's crazy,
joe is like,
I'd be scared to go hunting trip out.
Like I don't know.
I'd be scared like,
I dunno,
like I will look at like if I was going
to shoot a deer,
I don't know why,
but we from full,
like I don't,
I wouldn't fucking know how did you know
what I mean?
Or like,
I dunno,
it's crazy.
I trip out,
my dad hunted and I was like,
Nah,
I ain't doing that shit.
I'm scared.
Scared of what the will we be scared?
Like I'm going to like,
I don't know,
like I'm scared like the deer's fucker
with me and like there's like someone
else can come get me from over here.
Like I'm in their world.
Right.
I don't know.
It feels like
their world.
That's the weirdest part about the
woods.
When you're hunting in the woods,
you lock eyes with an animal.
It's,
it's,
it's almost like it's almost psychedelic
in some sort of a weird way like brings
you to another.
It's like you feel like you're in
another dimension.
It's.
I know that sounds so stupid when I say
it,
even I hear it myself,
but when you lock eyes and then when
you're hunting,
you lock eyes an animal,
the whole world changes.
It's like the whole thing.
You're in there and you're in a totally
different environment.
An environment that doesn't give a fuck
about you.
It doesn't care if you look like you're
used to your street.
Oh,
this is the deli that I eat at.
This is where I do my laundry,
you know,
it's all normal stuff.
Like you have these patterns and you
just see people and you see cars and
like this is my world,
but then when you're in their world you
realize like,
oh,
this is a totally different world.
This is like I went to another planet.
Yeah,
fuck yeah.
I mean people try to get me to go
camping.
I'm like,
Nah,
I'm cool it.
Oh Man,
you'd love it.
This thing about it is you get used to
it after awhile and it becomes normal
and then once it becomes normal you
realize like how peaceful it is.
Like we just sitting down in the grass
like,
like on a top of a mountain,
like looking out at a valley and you go,
God,
this is so like you would pay like fuck
museums,
like go to the La County Museum of art
and they see these bullshit exhibits.
They have their.
They're terrible to look at it.
Don't do a goddamn thing for you.
Most of the modern abstract art,
it's fucking ridiculous stupid.
But I challenge anyone to go,
go to Colorado,
go to boulder,
Colorado and at the mountains,
go into the mountains and look at some
of those peaks.
Look at the continental divide.
It's like the most incredible piece of
art you could ever see and it's just
nature does something to you.
You had me and red van just got back
from Denver and it was,
it was cool.
Denver's the shit.
I was first time there,
so I wasn't used to like,
I guess somebody told me there's no
water around,
so you get headaches.
Well,
it's not that there's no water,
it's a year at a very high altitude and
dehydration comes quicker for whatever
reason.
So you have to keep yourself hydrated is
super important.
I guess he's just dry out the
environment,
but uh,
people are cool as fuck.
And Denver is like one of the best.
It was always cool,
but you know,
Denver for a long time the city of
Denver just didn't have weed laws.
They're like,
forget it.
We don't give a fuck.
You smoke weed,
do whatever you want to do.
We don't care.
Like it was like when I first started
working there,
which I don't even know when I first
started working,
there was a long time ago,
but I remember the club owners will tell
you like,
this city is essentially made.
We'd decriminalized like,
you don't,
you won't get arrested for weed.
They just don't arrest people for weed.
That's awesome.
That was a long time ago.
Then the state was the first to get
gangster and say,
fuck you federal government,
it's legal,
so you could buy weed everywhere in
Denver.
Now in Colorado there are weeds stores
everywhere now.
So because of that,
the economy's booming.
Real estate prices,
I think they went up 14 or 16 percent
inside of two years.
Drunk driving deaths dropped to an all
time low.
Violent crime dropped to an all time
low.
It's amazing.
Pills,
pill and opiod addiction dropped to an
all time low.
Yeah.
Fuck those days.
Well,
that's what's going on right now in
Arizona.
I don't know if you've been paying
attention,
but they're trying to pass it in
Arizona.
They're trying to pass legal weed in
Arizona and the opposition has been
alcohol companies and pain pills.
Those are the ones who spend the most
money trying to keep weed illegal.
My buddy grows like legally and he told
me that they invented this new light
that makes sure we'd grow faster,
but all the tobacco companies got
together and bought all those lights.
So every time this guy puts out new
lights,
the tobacco company buys them all.
Wow.
And I,
I mean,
I haven't looked into it and then he
goes,
the only other reason we can't make it
legal here is because every time they
put the thc in the rolling things to
mix,
like to put them in cigarettes,
it gets too sticky and it misses the
machines up.
And I was just like,
I never even thought of that.
So just hire people to do it by hand.
Go to Gino La.
That's why they have these tubes folks.
See people don't understand people that
live in other barbaric parts of America,
whether it's hard to get weed,
we get these joints and they're exactly
the same every time.
Look at that.
It's God damn perfect.
Got a little paper tube at the bottom.
We'd all sits in the top.
The problem with this stuff is like you
said,
this is medicine.
It's like medicine for life,
but if you smoke it,
people think you're loser.
That's me out.
Now they think that you're a druggie and
you're a fool.
Something's wrong with.
You fucked her
chart of Bullshit George for.
You know what's weird is I have a 20
year old son and he smokes weed and I
kind of feel like an asshole because I'm
like,
you can't smoke that shit around me.
He's like,
why?
And I said just cause like I just always
want to feel like your dad,
like just give me.
I gave that to my dad.
You got to let it go.
I've got a 20 year old daughter.
She smokes weed.
Wrong with it in front of you.
And like not really,
but she's had wine in front of me once.
Oh yeah.
But he wants me to roll it for him and
it looks and I don't think there's
anything wrong with it.
I think I'd be a hypocrite if I said
there was,
she's a smart girl,
she knows what the fuck is up,
you know?
And when she was younger her mother
caught her with it and there's like this
big deal.
I'm like,
bitch,
you smoke weed,
why you getting mad at her?
But it's one of those things where you
feel like you're supposed to get mad at
people I suppose to tell them.
I'm like,
listen,
this is not bad for you,
but there are drugs that are bad for
you,
so if I told you that this is bad for
you and you realized it wasn't bad for
you,
first of all,
it would be a massive hypocrite because
I have tattooed on my body
massive hypocrite and plus I knew she's
on Youtube.
She's seen videos mean it's ridiculous.
I talk about weed all the time,
but more importantly,
she wouldn't trust me about things that
are bad for you.
I'd be like,
stay the fuck away from that peanut
butter crank is actually bad for you.
And I told her,
I said,
we had a nice long discussion.
I've never done anything that's
addictive other than alcohol and I don't
have whatever genetic predisposition to
get addicted to alcohol,
but I've never fuck with coke.
I've never fucked with crank.
I've never fucked with heroin because I
don't want to ruin my life.
I said,
but there are some drugs that they're
fun.
As long as you're using them in
moderation.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with trying mushrooms.
If you do it in a safe setting,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with smoking a little weed.
I think there's plenty of things that
people would throw under the same
classification as drugs that they're
just not bad for you,
man.
They're just not.
You know,
you're right.
You're right.
I just,
I dunno,
I kinda like that little.
It's like a little Mexican thing.
It's like the machismo illness.
Like my dad was like,
you don't do that shit in front of me.
Yeah.
So I'm glad you told me that.
Hey Jordan,
a blazer with you.
When I go home for Georgia,
we're going to blaze it.
He's a man.
He's 20 years old.
That's a man.
You know.
My daughter is a woman.
She's a woman.
Just as assistants thing,
man,
when you're looking at life,
you know we have classifications for
people,
but when a person reaches a certain age,
like man,
that is a.
that's a grown ass human being.
That person could have babies of their
own.
They could go to war,
they could start a family,
they could start a business.
You know,
it's,
I had a kid when I was 18.
That's crazy,
man.
Yeah.
He's 20 now.
I could've easily.
We all could've.
Right.
Anybody who's having sex could have
easily had a kid when they're,
you know,
whatever age
you started.
Most people they fuck up.
They have sex with no condom.
They make mistakes.
Yeah.
That was,
that was some wild shit.
His mom was the wild one.
She's the crazy one.
Crazy because you still keep in touch
with her.
Uh,
fuck.
I mean now.
I mean he sees her once in a while,
but I have had custody of him ever since
he was five years old.
He live with,
you know,
he's lived with me ever since he was
five because you want to do stand up.
He did for a little bit,
but he is more like a,
I don't know,
like he's more like both of my kids.
I wish I could have been them because
they,
they weren't.
I felt like I felt like I was a follower
when I was a teenager because I want it
to be like a surfer skater,
but I also wanted to be a gangster
there.
Surfers,
skaters and their living life.
Like they love it.
I love it,
and my son lives by the beach.
He serves.
He's like,
oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
he works at in and out.
My other son does choir,
like all the things I wanted to do.
They're doing,
so that's what I'm just like.
Well,
you will honest and you talk about
things real honestly.
And from that they can see like
mistakes.
Oh yes.
And then not have to go through them
themselves.
It's like I think parents that aren't
honest about mistakes,
I think they do themselves a disservice
the way they raise their kids because
your kid doesn't get to learn from your
own fuck ups.
You know?
I think kids need to know that you're
infallible or that you're not
infallible,
that you make mistakes.
You're just a human.
And that,
I think I used to do this bit,
but it really does kind of apply is that
when you were little,
like remember when you were little used
to think that they were real grownups
because he used to like get upset about
something.
You go one day,
it wouldn't be a grownup and
everything's going to make sense,
but it's never going to make sense.
It's never going to make.
So I'm 49 years old.
This doesn't make sense.
None of this makes sense to me.
It doesn't make sense at all.
It's crazy.
It's the life to this day still so
bizarre.
There's no grownups.
You just get older and then one day you
realize like,
oh look,
I just gotta find out how to be happy.
That's all you have to do.
How to find out,
be happy and create comradery,
like create comradery amongst your
friends and amongst your family and
amongst the people that you love.
Spread as much as you can.
Like that's what this is all about.
Straight up.
Just try to enjoy it as much as you can.
Whatever this is,
enjoy as much as you can.
Everything else is a trap.
All the other thoughts or traps,
collecting the most shit and having the
biggest house and all that being the
most famous are selling most records or
whatever the fuck you do.
You know,
selling the middle of the most million
dollar houses.
Almost all the bullshit has some people
just go out on missions.
Man.
I got her brother like that.
I love you,
but he's Terry.
Like I think he made me how I am.
I got,
I got five brothers.
All my older brothers are like teachers,
like super successful.
Not that I'm not,
but it's just like
you can tell where it just turned with
me because my older brother,
he was a captain of the football team
since like sixth grade.
This was a captain,
played football.
Marshall Fall gets his masters and he's
a trip.
He was just so hard on,
like drill me all the time,
dude.
He used to take me to the park and be
like,
Hey,
that guy kicks your ass.
I'm going to kick your ass.
Go fight.
And I'd be like,
what the fuck?
Am I crazy leadership?
Oh yeah.
And,
and he was like in leadership programs
and shit like that.
And I did.
And look at me now I remember I told
him,
I go,
hey man,
you keep pushing,
you keep pushing.
Your son is going to end up just like
me,
like,
chill,
chill.
My brother was just like chet from weird
science.
That's hilarious.
But shorter than me and just super
educated in thug.
It was weird.
Super educated and thug.
Yeah.
Like he could kick all my friend's ass,
eh.
Fuck.
It was really smart too.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Did you ever get involved in martial
arts?
Uh,
no.
Probably should have done that.
That's probably would have been as
calling.
He probably could have like maybe like
alleviated some of that stress.
So that tension that he has,
you know what?
It's weird as they hit,
he coached his kids now and like he's so
different and like he,
yeah,
I think he got his mellow.
Yeah.
Well you had kids of his own.
Beautiful little son.
Yeah.
But that'll do it.
He's so competitive to this day.
Like I remember somebody was like,
Hey,
I seen your comedy central roles bottle.
He was like,
yeah,
but I graduated from Chapman.
I was like,
fuck,
can I have something that's hilarious.
He doesn't just want to say you did
great.
Yeah.
It held time and like I did good on
something else.
You know what I usually think I used to
think,
oh well that guy just fuck those guys.
Those guys are pains in the ass is too
hard to deal with them.
Then I realized what those guys are is
like super winters that never found a
venue.
Like sometimes there's super winters,
like there's certain people I really
think in order to be a Michael Jordan or
anybody that's like a super winter,
you,
you almost have to be imbalanced to the
point where you want to succeed.
You want it all about you way more than
the average person and that creates a
lot of like relationship,
like a,
a block in the harmony because you're.
You're always thinking about yourself.
Like I think a lot of those guys don't
find the venue.
They don't find it a real thing to be
competitive with it,
but if they did,
they would get all those lumps.
Especially with martial arts,
especially with Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is a big one man,
and if you can get through that,
you get all those lumps,
you get choked down all the time.
You get your ass kicked all the time and
through getting your ass kicked all the
time,
getting strangled and tapped out.
You,
you learn how to control your ego better
and then you learn like what's actual
and what
is.
You just talk and shit.
Like how much of this is real?
You know what I mean?
You're like,
yeah,
because like had Jordan,
he was just soaring from college all the
way up,
but you can't do that when you get your
Jujitsu black belt,
right?
You know,
you can still,
you know,
you can compete.
You,
you could certainly.
I mean the guys who were the best in the
world,
all of them are completely obsessed with
competing and training in Jujitsu,
but I think just for men sometimes it's
good to have some sort of an avenue for
aggressive behavior.
Just get it out of the way so you can
chill out car raiders games.
I really think that that's what a lot of
Douchey guys are missing in their life.
They're missing that outlet.
I agree with you to the in some girls
too.
Girls now are just a VC.
I've seen more girls fight each other.
Then I've seen guys fight each other at
clubs.
Yeah.
I go to youtube.
I don't go to clubs.
I've watched that.
Tough from a distance,
but yeah,
girls beat the fuck out of each other.
Now that they've seen all these mma
girls who know how to beat the fuck out
of each other.
We Ronda Rousey.
Well first.
Gina Carano and Cris Cyborg though.
Those were the first ones.
Like Gina Carano was the first female
superstar,
but it never got as big as it is with
the UFC.
Like when Ronda Rousey became the first
female superstar mixed martial artist,
he became the first woman where dudes
how to look at each other and go,
do you think she can kick your ass guys?
But like,
fuck no.
And the other guy be like,
fuck yes.
She'd kick your ass.
No,
she wouldn't bro.
No yet.
No,
no,
no guy.
She would kick your and they have these
conversations.
That's like literally the first time
ever.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I've had them in,
in the fights or started becoming a
fighter because of her probably a giant
number.
Fuck yeah.
You know,
I,
I would love to see like a
Chola come out of prison and get into
that shit,
you know,
especially if she could get good.
She had a good coach.
So much of it man.
Yeah.
The coaching giant giant save you George
Perez where young guy liked to fight and
uh,
you went to the wrong place and they
taught you bad things.
They taught you.
They have poor habits.
Their patterns like how they fight is
too predictable to know,
have a well rounded game or you get
lucky.
You could go to like for us a hobby and
Montreal.
It,
a few guys,
a handful of guys that are like the best
guys in the world and you meet them and
you realize like,
oh shit,
I got really lucky.
I found someone with like this deep
reservoir of martial arts knowledge,
but there's only like 20 or 30 of those
guys on the planet earth.
There's such a small number of really
good mixed martial arts in particular
instructors this other.
There's a bunch of really good a
traditional martial arts instructors
like Jujitsu instructors,
a ton of really good ones,
a ton a taekwondo,
same a lot for Moitai,
but as far as like mma,
just the full like what martial arts
really are today is the whole thing.
It's so hard to separate.
It's good to separate
in terms of like understanding who's the
best at each individual skill,
like who's the best Jujitsu guy on the
planet is not necessarily who the best
mma fighter on the planet is.
There's a difference and if the best MMA
fighter on the planet competed in
Jujitsu against the best Jujitsu guys,
they'd probably lose,
and if the best Jujitsu guy competed
against the MMA fighter in mma,
they would most likely lose.
So it's.
It's a real balance.
You got to get as more right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's a balance and put that balance
together.
There's a handful of people on the
planet.
Fun.
Yeah.
It's a.
So if you know,
a young guy,
I wanted to become a martial artists,
like it's so important to find a good
school.
It's everything.
You could find someone who's a
knucklehead that just likes teaching,
you know,
they like hearing their own voice and
they,
you know,
they have their own system and they act
like an asshole and act like a tough
guy.
You could run into one of those,
like we played a video in here a couple
of weeks back of this,
I guess it was from the eighties,
says karate instructor.
They took this homeless guy off the
street and they,
they beat the fuck out of him on this
video.
Stuff.
Stomp his head while it's on the ground
is hard whore,
super hard to watch.
But if you're a kid you could stumble
into that guys,
Jim or you can stumble into AMC.
Pankration in Washington state with Matt
Hume.
It's like one of those small handful of
guys to the best in the world.
You can get lucky or you could fuck up
like comedies like that to hell yeah.
Hell yeah.
Fuck yeah.
I've had a break.
So many bad habits.
Yeah.
Well if you start off in the wrong spot
around the wrong people,
you think that's what comedy is,
where you can get lucky.
You know,
you can get lucky and be in New York
City,
you know,
you can be lucky and be,
at the saddler and stand and walk around
seeing all these comics.
Just Bang it out and constantly writing
and developing new material or you could
fuck up and you can be born and you
know,
some weird midwest state that doesn't
have a comedy scene.
You got to figure out how to fucking get
on stage somewhere.
Yeah.
Fuck that man.
If you're stuck somewhere that doesn't
have a comedy scene,
you want to try comedy moving is fucking
hard,
man.
Yeah.
Dude,
I live in Orange County and people are
like,
hey,
why don't you go into Hollywood?
I'm like,
dude,
I still like,
I'm close to you.
Like I don't have to be there,
but so happy that I'm fucking from
Orange County because I can go to
Ontario,
San Diego,
all these other clubs that will take you
guys three hours.
The only takes me an hour.
Yeah.
So fuck yeah,
I got lucky.
Well this whole area is a great book.
Contrary to what people would think is a
great place to start.
And there's also because the comedy
store has so many comics that went from
being like door people to being
headliners.
Like everybody who's a comic at the
comedy store is a comic,
you know,
there's like a group of all of us and
we're all in the mix together from the
guys who are still.
I mean I had one of the door guys on the
podcast
before.
I think that when,
when you do stand up comedy,
you do stand up comedy,
you know,
and I think that anything else like
looking at it in any other way is a,
is kind of,
it's,
it's kind of short sighted.
You know,
we're all in this weird thing together
in some weird way.
I hear you.
Like when I first started,
I didn't even,
it was forbidden to go to the store,
like felt like I was told,
oh did they don't take Mexicans there?
And I was like,
Oh,
who told you that?
I remember like,
what year was this?
It's like 2000 to 2001.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
no,
I was like.
And then like somebody making shit up.
Yeah.
Then I meet like Luke Torres and Johnny
Sanchez and they're like,
hey,
we gotta start at the time I was like,
ah,
fuck,
fuck yeah,
lucky to be there now.
I love that place.
It's a learning so much.
And like it's a trip because like
somebody told me that it's,
it's the place for the zoo and I was
just like,
that's exactly what I am look at being
like no other,
no other clubs going to look at me and
be like,
we want you to be the MC.
Well I remember I saw you a first time.
I saw you there a while back.
You were doing a roast battle and the
first thing I sent,
it's like,
this dude looks different than these
other people.
Dangerous about this guy,
like I've been around enough dangerous
people were like dangerous people almost
have like a smell to them.
Like don't,
don't,
don't get stupid,
you know,
some people that I don't think they
smell that I don't think that like I can
meet someone,
I swear to God and if it's a guy who's
been through a lot of shit you can tell
pretty quickly and it talking to them
like that.
They've legitimately seen a lot of
character testing shit.
Like getting involved in prison riots
are beating the fuck out of a guy and
break his orbital bone or a basketball
game.
How these people,
people that have done shit like that,
they have like a field to them.
It's interesting because I saw you doing
your Rosebud.
First of all,
you were very funny things like sharp,
funny well-worded insults,
which is like what [inaudible] is all
about.
It's really what they've done is created
a,
an amazing,
um,
sort of a writer's show.
Yeah.
Really about performing and coming up
with good ideas and good jokes.
And it's cool because it gives a guy
like me a chance to go against people
that I will never meet or ever hang out
with and like dude,
like they get to be in front of you raw.
It's like all these guys that get to see
them instead of seeing them at a coffee
shop.
Yeah.
I liked that show.
It's amazing.
It's a great show.
It's fucking funny as hell too,
man,
you know.
But so I remember seeing you there and
then hearing your story and I was like
God damn,
that's crazy story.
Like you have so much stuff that you
could mine into to it.
It's like
the fucking,
it gets even crazier because like,
you know,
nobody ever asked me like this is the
crazy shit joe is.
Prison was a fucking piece of cake.
The hardest shit was coming home.
And like it's Kinda like you go away for
a war.
Like I remember coming home like
I was the neat freak forever.
And like I try to treat everybody in my
house.
Like there are inmates,
hey who the fuck left hair?
Kids are like,
Dad,
my bath and oh yeah,
like I couldn't be around people too
close.
Like wow,
if I went to the store,
like I looked at,
night is a Homie,
I'm paying you here,
and then people are like fuck is wrong
with this guy.
I would never text nobody at all.
Nobody would answer my call.
And then what the fuck is.
No one's answering my call.
He wants to answer calls anymore.
Yeah,
it's strange,
right?
A lot of weird shit about getting out.
It was the fucking transition of
transitions.
And so you were institutionalized.
Institutionalized.
Yeah.
Straight up.
And they were only in there for three
years,
man.
Imagine if you were in there for 20,
25.
Fuck.
Well it's Kinda like how you say it,
it's who you affiliate yourself with and
then you know when you come from your
street,
there's codes that just,
you're taught from the beginning of
they're going to follow you in there.
So it's Kinda like I was taught by the
right people in the codes to go in there
and just to come out and to finally
realized like,
Hey,
I'm not even going to gang bang no more.
I don't even give a fuck.
You can call me what you want to call
me.
I'm living life now for my kids and then
for me and then I need this new
generation.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that was the whole weird transition
as well as just like being on parole.
Fuck.
That was embarrassing.
Dissolve.
Is there a feeling like hoping that you
could pull it off?
Like when you,
when you.
I would imagine that something like
parole,
one of the big issues would be that if
you know that someone's watching you and
checking up on you all the time and
evaluating you all the time,
that puts almost additional pressure on
you to fuck up.
There's like a psychological thing that
happens to people when you,
you know what you were talking about,
your brother putting all that pressure
on you and then you respond from it.
Like there's a,
there's a pressure that you put on
someone when you're monitoring their
behavior and I understand that you have
to do it,
especially if someone's committed
violent crimes and you gotta make sure
that they're doing all right and not do
anything stupid.
You let them free.
Right.
I can understand it,
but I'm just saying that psychologically
it probably has an adverse effect on the
person.
Like that's gotTa fuck with your head
man.
Fuck yeah,
it,
it's shit.
You know,
it would feel like to have to check in
with so fuck.
It sucks because it's kind of like
imagine having a girlfriend that can
just be like,
no,
fuck you bitch.
You're going to prison.
Oh man,
that's exactly what it is.
It's like you have to like why didn't
you answer my call?
And I was like,
I was on stage asshole.
My bad,
I was working.
I can't answer it.
And he was like,
oh,
they have a power trip on you.
Yeah.
They power trip and plus I was a high
risk in me.
So your high control when you're on
parole,
they,
they get you as a session.
I'm a high risk inmate or normal parole,
no parole.
All you do is check in once a month.
They don't come to your house.
Maybe you piss test.
I have to go into that office once a
week,
Piss test.
Every time I go,
wow.
And he comes to visit me with only an
hour notice.
Only an hour notice.
Sometimes if you're lucky,
sometimes just outside Christ.
That's so crazy,
man.
And this is the crazy part is this guy
thought I was drug dealing because I
just got out of prison and I wasn't you
on parole for three years.
So my first year I got out and I
couldn't work it out in my baby's mom.
She was different and I became a
different person.
I wasn't that gangster that,
you know what I mean?
I came out like,
Nah.
So we just went our own ways.
My buddy just got a divorce and he had a
bad ass house in Anaheim hills and he
goes,
hey dog,
like the bank's going to take the house.
I think you have like a year.
You could stay in there.
He was like,
I don't want to stay there.
I hate that fucking house.
Me and my wife divorced,
so I was staying at this house for free
and just paying the bills and my parole
officers.
Like,
how in the fuck,
how still he saw that you were dealing
drugs?
Slang in a hilarious.
And then like he was cool though because
like he uh,
he finally like treating me like I was a
normal person.
He confessed to me once,
he's like,
man,
this is bullshit George.
I mean he's like,
I'm getting a fucking divorce.
He was getting divorced too and I guess
they were cutting all the parole
officers there are there.
We're doing a cut.
So Cincinnati,
he had bad credit.
He couldn't be a casino.
Wow.
Bad credit.
Yeah.
If you have bad credit,
you can't be a casino cup.
I wonder why.
I wonder if they think that you're too
desperate for money probably.
And then we might be able to accept
bribes from people or something
properly.
But that was the only time that guy ever
like talked to me besides just like.
And it'd be like,
Hey,
take a piss in front of me.
You know how weird that is?
Real weird to look at your Dick,
right?
The a rubber Dick.
No.
For real people have been caught with
those visitors.
Now what you do is you put bleach under
your finger now or the special thing
that's like no advanced.
That's what Joey Diaz says.
Yeah.
She said he put it.
He put the clorox.
Yeah,
under the forest.
Skin of his dick.
He was talking about it.
I one time he said he put Draino there
too.
I used to put coffee on my balls when I
went to court coffee.
I put it in a plastic bag and a rubber
band and wrap it around my and go to
court.
But he looked like a pimp.
It's going to court everyone.
Urine like 50 people in a jail cell.
Right?
And you're just right there and nothing
to do.
I want some coffee on me for real.
It's like that.
And everyone was shooting it.
And it's like when you're in there,
you want it to be just like this a man.
There's no responsibility.
But just to be cool and be strong and
fucking let's have fun.
Dog.
Wow.
So you knew to keep coffee on your ball
so you could have it once he'd be in
prison?
No,
this is when I
know that I'm already in prison,
but sometimes you've got to go to court.
So I was going to court to get my
license back because you have the right
to get your license back.
Even though you're in prison,
you still have the right.
So they're like,
all right,
fuck it.
We'll send you.
So I tied it because knowing like Ada,
there's not going to be no coffee for
us,
but when I pull up to this and the home
is going to be like,
because you don't get in trouble for
sneaking coffee.
They'll just like a stupid ass talk shit
to you.
But it was,
it was just like bragging,
having fun.
Right.
Sorry.
That was weird.
Huh?
That's funny though.
That's hilarious.
Thinking about balls and coffee together
and no one's even like,
oh watch out is no one gives a phone
even spoon,
spoon,
spoon home.
There's hot water in the restroom at
there.
We'd get it from the sink.
Pretty Weird.
Strange.
When you think about it or does it seem
like like normal.
Does it feel like.
Because it seems to me like you're,
you're obviously you moved past that
you're doing well as a standup comedian
now you're out,
but when you're talking about it,
this part of you that,
you know,
that kind of misses the fuck.
Yeah,
you can see it.
It's like,
yeah,
but you don't want to go back.
Never crazy,
isn't it?
Yeah.
It's just like,
I don't know man,
like it's Kinda like
I was places with people for a long time
that like became family to me for that
and like,
I dunno,
I'm that Kinda guy that like a man when
I'm your friend,
I'm your friend and like they're still
my friends.
I'm like,
I know a lot of people.
This is what I've been told by a lot of
people at.
You're the only format that when he got
out,
answered my fucking phone call and
didn't like people forget about you.
They don't want nothing to do with you.
It's happened to me where I've caught up
with La Homie.
That was just prison dog.
I was like,
Oh shit.
My bad.
So yeah.
Oh Wow.
So you get out of prison.
They don't want have nothing.
Oh yeah,
I could.
I could see people wanting to move on
with their lives to man.
I just think.
But prison itself is so.
It's gotta be so devastating.
It's so crazy how many people we have
locked up.
When you look at the numbers are telling
you the truth.
I did not know.
Like now they got t bunks now like the.
You don't even have day room.
No more.
So you're in a prison.
This just say this is a prison right
here.
Along the wall there it'd be cells and
in the middle of where to be where you
eat.
Now they have t bunks.
They have bunks that are screwed into
the concrete and people sleep like with
no protection.
Imagine that Shit.
Wow.
You and 50 other inmates.
Just an a bunk in someone's big living
room.
Yeah.
It's getting overpopulated.
The numbers are so insane though.
Yeah,
and it's crazy.
I don't mean to cut you off,
but this is,
this is what trips me out.
I was like,
I had friends that I was locked up with
and like in Wasco reception,
so people come in and out and my friends
are like,
oh yeah,
everybody on this side,
they get sent to Mississippi and then
they send all those like they're sending
our inmates to Mississippi,
Alabama,
Michigan and Michigan and never getting
a check from us and then at the end they
bring us back and they send us home from
somewhere over here.
Yeah.
There's never been a time in history
where a country is locked up more with
citizens 10 right now.
I can't imagine there's ever been a
time.
I mean I'm saying that pretty
confidently,
but I think they said that United States
has more prisoners than it was a giant
number when they compared it to the rest
of the world.
Like how many prisoners?
The will just look it up like the United
States prisoners in comparison to
prisons combined the rest of the world
because it's insane how many we have
locked up.
We got more prisoners and illegal
immigrants in California,
I'm sure.
Right?
Yeah,
but what the fuck is the solution to
that?
Like that's a broken society.
If you have a million people locked up
or whatever the hell we have locked up.
Don't we have something like a million?
How many.
But like where does the funding come
from?
Is What trips me out?
I was like,
how are they getting so much money off
of it?
Well,
there's a bunch of different ways.
First of all,
it's a business.
Whenever a company is getting paid
because people are in jail,
that's a business.
Even if it's a state business or if it's
a private business,
there's still businesses because they
cost money and they cost money and
people get paid to work there.
So as soon as people get paid to work
there,
they want to keep those jobs.
That's always going to be a problem and
people get paid to work in prisons.
They're going to keep those jobs also.
They lobby the lobby hard.
The prison guard union lobby,
cops lobby 2 million,
220,300 adults were incarcerated
in 2013.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Additionally,
4 million,
750.
One thousand 400 adults in 2013 were on
probation or parole.
So that's a lot do.
That's one in every 51 people is on
parole.
That is fucking crazy.
That's crazy.
Now once you're on parole,
like you stay in the system,
that is a crazy number,
man.
That's.
There's obviously too many things that
are illegal.
There's a lot of people that want to do
these things.
We've got to figure out what's violent
crime,
what's.
You know,
what's crime?
What's violent crime?
What's what's,
what's.
What does everybody agree?
Can't do camp kill people.
Everybody agrees like certain Shit.
Figuring out what that is and now all
that other shit you're locking people up
for.
Stop.
Stop it.
Well,
they get paid.
It's like you said,
like every public defender gets what?
800 bucks for every time someone signs
for time and.
But then there's also private prisons
was also prisons that get paid to the
mean they are a business.
They start a prison so that they can
make money by having people locked in
their cages.
That's probably sub them out and do work
around the highway and stuff and make
money off of that.
Huh?
Probably,
probably don't.
I don't know,
but I would imagine if they made people
work in your prison and we've always
seen people working in prisons.
I would.
I would always assume that that's a big
part of it.
And you could make boots you make every.
We make our own boots,
our own clothes in there too because one
of my earliest jokes when I was like,
it was probably a hack joke and I don't
even know it,
but when I was a kid,
a live free or die was on the New
Hampshire license plate and I was like,
imagine that.
Live free or die.
What's fucked up about it as those
plates are being made by prisoners so
they're in jail and they were right in
live free or die on a plate.
Like what the fuck that was to be.
Kill yourself.
Kill Yourself,
kill yourself.
That was one of my earliest jokes.
Probably one of 10 guys to come up with
it though,
because it's so obvious that you know,
that was always the big thing,
right?
License plates.
Yeah.
License plates and now it's everything.
Frigerators might make refrigerators in
prison.
It was always license plates.
So when we were kids,
right.
That was always saying prisoners.
Prisoners and license plates were
connected for some strange reason.
I didn't like in Mississippi and down
south.
They made the railroads,
didn't they?
Probably.
Uh,
I know they actually really did break
rocks in some places.
They literally make gravel
sledgehammers.
Oh,
that's a great workout.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's the best workout.
I used to swing a sledge when a
deconstruction.
I was a form center.
I had an eight pounder and 10 pounder
sometimes when we had rough dirt.
Well,
they do that a lot with like mma
conditioning classes.
They have people hit sledge hammers on
tires and shit.
What's this?
Young Jamie?
Thirteen 11 products you might not know
where made but prison.
Oh,
books for the blind.
Lingerie.
Oh Shit.
These dudes are making laundry Victoria
secrets and JC penney hired
subcontractor.
Third Generation who in turn hire people
stitch their laundry and leisure wear.
How many of those dudes lik those
panties put them in those packages?
How many of them rubbed their ball sack
on him?
That make come on,
but that's why women want them to
because they're like,
a convict made this.
Yeah,
that's the good.
They smell it.
I smell danger and those panties park
benches and picnic tables.
Wow.
Military Jackets in battle garb.
That's an interesting one.
A federal prison industries,
but this is nuts.
Better known as Unicor.
Consistent tiredly of convicts working
in 89 factories together.
They help clothe the United States
military making jackets,
uniforms,
helmet shoes,
and even flak vests for police officers.
They craft body armor and holsters.
You know what they're going to say in
the future?
They're going to look back and they're
going to go,
oh,
this is hilarious.
Pop Point in history,
because the people then didn't know that
they had slaves.
They didn't.
They didn't think slavery existed.
They were like,
slavery doesn't exist anymore.
They didn't.
But meanwhile that is exactly what
slavery is.
Regardless of what they did.
If someone murdered someone and someone
I can,
this is an argument that they should be
locked up,
but when they're working for thirty
eight cents an hour because they
murdered somebody and they're making
shit that people are buying their
slaves.
Yes.
If just the government's buying it,
that's a slave,
right?
Fuck yeah.
I just thought of that right now.
I was like,
fuck,
I feel as a slave for three years.
It's a slave.
You know,
because people have always said slavery
as barbaric.
If you didn't know our culture and you
know,
we accept this form of slavery as being
punishment,
restitution and you didn't know that.
Some people that are in there absolutely
don't deserve to be in there or were
railroaded on fault trumped up charges.
That's there's a percentage,
whether it's 100 or whatever the fuck it
is.
That person's a real person in jail
right now and they're working as a slave
to make body armor that's thirty eight
cents an hour.
Fuck you.
That slavery is slavery.
Just figured out a way to make it.
Okay.
I figured out a way to make it.
Okay,
look at this.
Colorado correction industries overseas,
approximately 60 inmate work programs.
Jailbirds at Fremont County jail,
for example,
build fiber,
glass sealed canoes.
They use scraps from the apprentice
prisons,
furniture shop and sell the canoes for
around 1500 bucks.
Other Colorado programs help craft those
ubiquitous college dormitory desks and
bookshelves.
Wow.
They make blue jeans.
Holy Shit.
A lot of jeans.
People by the Eastern Oregon
Correctional Institute is home for a
47,000 square foot facility.
Prison,
blue jeans factory,
getting plates a prisons.
Bluejean horses.
What does horses?
They train wild mustangs.
Prepping them for adoption.
That is hilarious.
We got to open up a prison horses.
They capture wild horses and train them
for adoption.
Did you know that that's an issue in
America right now?
I'm just just becoming aware of the
issue of wild horses.
There's a wild horse issue in America.
I mean like they have gotten free and
they've gone feral and they're wild and
apparently this tens of thousands of
them.
What are they attacking?
Anything.
Oh,
that's hacking.
Anything that out of danger.
It's just they're.
They're encroaching on farmland and
they're becoming a new.
We'll look at one point in time.
Horses roamed wild on the planes.
That was a long time ago,
long,
long time ago.
Then they actually went extinct in North
America and they were brought here from
other parts of the world where the rigid
originated in North America,
but they brought them other places so
there was a point in time somewhere in
history or horses did run wild around
here,
but they killed a lot of them.
They killed them and they used them.
They filled them with strychnine and fed
them to wolves to kill off the wolf
population because they were trying to
make everything safe for cattle.
Raising that fucking crazy dude.
Our country used to be this like kind of
wild area world is animals roam free,
but when cattlemen moved across the
country,
they started doing these wild horses.
You're showing US Jamie in Nevada,
in Nevada.
Nevada has thousands of them apparently,
but people see them there all the time.
I mean,
it's a common occurrence.
I mean these are like,
like deer or like anything else.
These are giant wild animals.
So what's really fucking weird fuck is,
you know,
people are talking about hunting these
things now because they're killing them.
And there were,
there were doing it in the,
uh,
the,
the early 19 hundreds.
They would kill them and make a dog food
out of them because they needed meat for
pets.
Like people really didn't have pets.
Like there wasn't like a pet food
industry the way there is today.
You know,
people just fed their pet,
whatever the fuck they fed up,
you know,
if you wanted a dog,
you feed him scraps or there was like a
big thing and a feed into your dog table
scraps.
But they started feeding them these
horses.
So they started killing all these horses
and they would kill horses for dog food
and they would kill horses and feed them
to the wolves.
But for whatever reason,
we didn't eat horses over here.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy.
Like,
so they were doing this in Denver or in
Nevada.
That's in Nevada.
Those,
those wild horses right there in that
video is wandered around the debt,
the high country desert,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
because we have that problem with a
cats.
I fucking flip out if it was horses in
the front of my fucking yard like that.
Well,
if you live out there,
man,
it's.
It's possible.
I mean,
I don't know how many there are.
The real problem is not like there's too
many horses.
The real problem is there's too many
horses that are going on with these
people's land that raised cattle and the
horses are grazing probably on the same
fields that cattle are and they're
getting pissed off taking the grass.
Yeah,
that's most likely what it is.
If I had to guess,
it's just a bunch of greedy cattle guys
who don't know.
They don't want to lose greedy,
whatever.
They're trying to protect their industry
to protect their interest.
I understand that,
but like at a certain point in time,
we have to step in I think as humans and
go,
well,
is it a bad thing to have these horses?
Like,
you know,
what are they hurting?
They think they seem pretty cool.
It's kind of cool to have wild horses,
isn't it?
Can we all agree?
It's kind of bad.
They seem to be thriving and you're
going to have to,
they're going to have to figure out a
way to manage their population because,
um,
they,
they're not going to get jacked by too
many mountain lions.
The way a deer do.
There is a horse that big animal and
then they kick.
No.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure a mountain lion could
kill a horse.
Don't get me wrong,
but I don't think that'd be a lot of fun
for the Mountain Lion Entirety Ensemble.
Yeah.
Do you think they'd bike back each other
up?
I get the horse.
Would they,
would they do in Africa like,
well,
like I'm that different hood to
different hoods,
but it is still cats and pray Predator
carnivores and herbivores.
The buffaloes in Africa,
they gang up and they go after lions.
Lions are attacking one of their own.
Oh yeah.
It's wild to see.
Right.
And I was little.
My parents had a ranch in Mexico.
I used to have a horse.
I love horses.
I didn't know how to tend to advice the
right that fucker once in a while.
Did you know that?
That.
Did you know the Aztecs or so tripped
out by horses?
They used to cut their heads off to.
Really?
Yeah.
I learned because,
uh,
that was the ritual.
They were offering a blood to the Sun
God.
Well,
so they would cut your head off and then
throw you down those steps.
And then
Linda Cortez came.
That's what they did to the people at
the end.
And they did it to the horses will.
When Cortez came,
wasn't that the first time they had ever
seen a person on a horse and they
thought the person was a part of the
horse?
Yes.
Yeah.
It never ceases wise in that crazy
imagine that you,
you've never seen someone ride a horse.
No one's ever written an animal.
I've never seen a horse.
Then also these dudes showed up riding
animals on a boat with like jackets on
and shit.
That would be like the,
you would be the biggest baller ever in
the world.
He pulled up in a boat and you stepped
off the boat and a horse,
you know,
you got a sword.
You're like,
who fucking dude,
he imagined those days.
Must have been so crazy.
You know what the crazy part is is they
say that Cortez tripped out when he was
like,
these fuckers have irrigation perfect
their sewers per.
Everything's bill perfect,
but why are they cutting people's heads
off and throwing these guys down the
steps?
Well,
if you look at the Mayan Pyramids and
some of the Aztec architecture that they
developed in that part of the world,
like they were on some crazy level that
very few civilizations have ever been on
the Mayan temples all aligned
constellations or at least most of them
too.
So they had some sort of a deep
knowledge and understanding of the.
What they were seeing in the solar
system is also a lot of evidence
apparently that they understood about
the wobble.
Like the earth has a wobble called the
procession of equinoxes and this wobble.
It still like the earth doesn't spin in
a perfect circle.
There are standing,
you know,
in this 26,000 year wobble and I think
it's 26,000 years,
but the point is it doesn't spin
perfectly in the stars.
Change their position in the sky
depending upon where in that cycle you
are.
Well,
the Mayans knew that they had outlined
that.
I mean they,
they developed some sort of a calendar
that has accurate,
if not more accurate than the calendar
we use today.
They had,
they had figured out some crazy shit.
Yeah,
I'm in prison.
I could.
That was like the thing you study,
like it was crazy.
I have a couple of tattoos of gods from
the Aztec.
This is a certain God,
like they're all certain gods and yeah,
it's all in that calendar.
It's pretty crazy.
Like I got the God on my of the day.
I was
born on the.
Look what God is at Sochi socially.
Both law.
It's weird because he was like,
he's a weird looking at your nipple,
but I'm going to let go.
Is that a prison one?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's good work.
Yeah.
This guy was solid right here.
He was with the business.
It's.
I would,
you know,
there's a few moments in history that I
would really love to go back and just be
like live in a,
in an invisible bulletproof bubble.
I just be able to sit in the middle of a
time and just watch these people,
but one of the big ones,
big ones.
I think if I had to choose one,
I think I'd have to take the Egyptian
pyramid two days.
Like I would love to see what the fuck
that looked like.
But right up there is I went to um,
a cheech and Anita went to the,
the staff here.
It's in,
um,
like close to,
uh,
Ken Kuhn.
It's like maybe an hour and a half
outside of Toronto.
Okay.
Mexico,
Mexico.
The Yucatan,
right?
Yes.
You done.
There's a couple of them down there.
There's a couple of different sites that
have these Mayan ruins,
but we went to teach nita and you're
walking around,
you're like,
what the fuck inspired them to do this?
This is,
that was the pyramid that we went up and
you got to realize we're talking more
than a thousand years ago.
They built this fucking thing and why?
Why they do it?
Like what is that they were really
infatuated by the sun.
Yeah.
And they would always like,
they felt when you gave the son blood
because they were so scared of dark,
they always wanted light.
Look at that structure.
Yeah,
I remember.
I remember going there and seeing that
and going,
who the fuck are these people?
Why they do this construction?
Every joint it's locked in.
Like our construction nowadays can't
lock joins huddles.
Joints are locked in.
Well they did an amazing job,
that's for sure.
The engineering is impeccable because
we're looking at it in perfect form
essentially except for a little bit
aware more than a thousand years later.
And it's just beautiful.
Like when you,
when you look at the construction of it
and you walk around,
you're like,
this is some serious engine on and it's
on the highest site.
So no flooding.
Yeah.
Like it's the way it faces the sun
there.
Yeah.
They killed a lot of fucking people on
that thing right there.
That was where they would cut dudes
fucking hearts out.
Yeah.
Right on top of that guy.
They would do it right on top of.
Is he like,
he's like a little tray for human
sacrifices.
He's actually,
he's actually a god.
They believed that he took those hearts
into the underworld.
You should check it out at some pretty
bad drawings.
Well,
I had a guide when I was there.
We hired this guy who was a professor at
a local university and he.
He doubled as a god and he gives you a
historical lesson about the entire
place.
It was amazing,
man.
It was amazing because this guy knew so
much about Mayan history and he also
said that they were really into eating
psychedelic plants.
He said that there was this place that
would go that had something had like
[inaudible] acid in it and they would,
which is one of the elements in the LSD
apparently like what is a lsd stand for
life surgery,
blah,
blah blah,
but allergic acid is in there,
but he was saying that they believed
that whatever they had was some sort of
a psychedelic lsd like compound and they
had this room and he took us to this
room where they would do it in there.
They had like a specific one of those in
one of the structures,
this specific room where they would do
their psychedelic rituals.
They were tripping their balls off.
That's how they saw that shit.
They're cutting people's heads off.
And have you ever seen apocalypto the
little kids right there,
telling them mom,
hurry up.
And it's like,
what the fuck is going on?
That's a crazy time in the world.
I would love to see that time.
Like when,
when,
um,
what's your other one?
You said Mayan.
Then you said the Egyptian.
You said you wanted to go to another
place another time.
Gaviscon.
Oh yeah.
You want to be around with that shit?
I want to see that.
I want to see what the fuck that was
like because uh,
to take them on or to join.
Oh No,
no,
no.
To Watch.
See how crazy life was back then.
I wouldn't want to live.
I wouldn't want to live in any of those
times,
but I would want to,
if I could have,
if someone does legitimately one day
come up with a time machine and say it,
it's like,
dude,
it's 10 grand.
But you can go back to Egypt for like
our pal people would totally save up.
I mean think about it costs a couple
thousand bucks if you're going to go to
Hawaii,
right?
Plane Fare and hotel room and then your
food,
you know,
you're,
you're into it,
right?
Yeah.
No,
10 grand more.
For how long,
how long are you in our one hour,
one hour and like this one hour in Egypt
during like some sort of ceremony and
actually be there and get a chance to
see it when Moses was in the river.
And
imagine what it would be like to see
those sacrifices that like when they
built.
What was it the pyramid of.
How do you say it too?
To ICAN?
How do you say that?
The Aztec pyramid.
See if he could find that that much shit
done.
They killed 80,000 people inside of a
few days and sacrifices not,
it's the religion.
That belief and
there was nothing to do,
but yeah.
Fuck,
I don't know.
Stop and think of that number.
80,000 people and they,
I believe it was within a few days,
I think they killed all the people that
worked on the pyramid.
All the slaves that worked on the
pyramid,
all of them got the knife I get.
They didn't want to pay.
Social security
were the first ones are like,
you fuckers getting work comp or
nothing.
How insane is that time of life like
that humans had agreed to that,
that that was going to be the.
That was,
that was the plan.
We got these slaves.
We got into build this thing and then
we're going to cut their hearts out.
Right.
We're cool with this.
Right?
Everybody's on board.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Let's cut their hearts out.
Like this is people.
This is human beings.
This is a totally different time in the
world and really not that long ago.
Yeah,
and it's kind of weird because it's like
they didn't even care.
Like if there was no more people left,
like how do they know there's not other
people left.
Right,
right.
David will be the last people down
cutting 85,000 dudes or 80,000 dudes
hearts out.
Imagine the guys I had to clean up all
that shit though.
80,000 bodies.
Ooh,
I bet they did a shitty job.
How about that?
I bet they weren't very motivated to
fucking kill me too,
man.
Yeah,
take your time.
Take your time.
I mean,
how is the body cleaner?
Well,
that was one of the things they said
about gangs con that when Genghis Kahn
died,
they buried him and then they killed all
the people that buried him and then they
killed the people that killed the people
that buried him.
Fuck,
that's a super
gangsters.
It gets you kill everybody.
Everybody that has any idea where he's
buried.
So no one could ever find the great con.
So only the guy that ordered the hit
nosa even he doesn't know far.
Everybody's dead.
The people that ordered,
they killed them too.
They killed everybody.
So no one knows.
No one knows where it is.
I just put a burn the body and acid and
be like,
good call.
No,
I think they have to have rituals.
Like I think you know,
in order to you,
if you're a Mongol order to make it to
the next stage of life,
you probably have.
They probably have some crazy rituals.
You're going to come back with a
motorcycle,
but that point in history seems like it
would be pretty insane.
They said the gang is con killed like 10
percent of the.
There was a New York Times article about
it that he killed 10 percent of the
world's population and he apparently
changed the carbon footprint of the
human race.
Meaning it killed so many fucking
people.
There was less soot in the air.
There was less carbon because of fires.
He's like,
it changed far away the foot.
What are residue on earth is when they
do those core samples.
That's saying,
man,
you gotta.
If anybody listening to this,
if you have it,
you've might have heard this before,
but I have to say it to people that
haven't hardcore history.
There's a guy named Dan Carlin,
he was on last week.
He's fucking awesome.
He's the best ever at like doing history
podcast.
That guy's a monster.
Him and Danielle.
Ebola.
He's awesome too,
but his,
he's got a series on the Gig is con days
called the wrath of the con.
It's a five part series.
You can get it on itunes.
It's like a dollar 99 a show or
something like that,
but there's hours and hours long folks
that are.
I can't,
I can't run,
it used to be free,
but he does like the first x amount of
free and then because he only does,
I'm like,
it takes months to put one of these out.
It's not like asking someone to pay for
a regular podcast.
It's like an audio book.
Okay.
Does he go out to all these places?
I don't think so.
I mean,
I don't know.
He studied,
uh,
the Mongols ever since he was in
college.
Who did a,
wrote a report about it?
It was part of the,
um,
the uh,
podcast series that he does on it.
He talks about his history with the
history of the Mongols,
but it's amazing and that's what got me
excited about the Mongols and starting
to check it out.
But I just would love to see what crazy
points in time looked like.
Like how as humans,
how we evolved with thinking and
fighting and shit like that.
Well,
you mean there's levels of craziness in
this world right now,
right?
Like somewhere there's some dudes that
are working as slaves making blue jeans
for some company,
right?
I mean,
and they're prisoners.
There's,
there's that world is a world that you
experience when you're in the county and
a riot breaks out.
This world is very different than the
world that most people experience.
But our world itself,
like the,
all the variables that we know that are
possible,
whether it's prison or or war or all
these things we know to be possible.
They are very different than it was a
thousand years ago or 2000 or whatever.
The Egypt was 4,500 plus years ago that
they were building the great pyramid.
Apparently fucking life would have been
crazy and insane.
I mean,
I can't even imagine what they say.
The Great Pyramid,
I think they said it's 2,500 BC when
they carbon tested to some of the stuff
in it,
which is 4,000 plus years ago,
you'd have to like hold your head how
you would hurt your head to think of how
long ago that was.
Hundreds and hundreds of years and
people living and dying and change
occurring and things in the climate
shifts and the,
uh,
you know,
the earthquakes,
feelings,
man,
so much craziness and it's so long and
if you go that far back,
these motherfuckers built some insane
shit that we can't barely built today.
We would have to have a team of
engineers from all over the world,
the biggest cranes ever to try to put
together one of those in just a,
you know,
in a decade or two decades.
Imagine that like the machines wouldn't
even work in that climate.
They wouldn't even know how to adjust to
the sand.
They'd have to make better machines.
Mean it could be done.
I think it can be done,
but it's not,
it's not simple.
What they did was so spectacular and the
idea that they did it 2,500 BC,
4,000,
500 plus years ago.
That's fucking crazy.
Hard to imagine they did that shit
before Jesus.
I would love to see it,
man.
I would love to see it.
I would just love to see what it looked
like back then like what happened?
Like the first day there were done.
Imagine how that just what it would be
like to live in that era.
Like what were their markets like,
what,
how smart were they?
Like I would love to be able to speak
their language and talked to one of them
from back then because I just think that
someone who builds that they must have
been insanely smart.
Insane.
But also.
I mean I agree with what you're saying,
but there were kind of like assholes
because they have slaves as well.
No,
that was a common misconception.
They thought that they had slaves until
pretty recently,
but now they realized by the quality of
the food and the pottery that they had
in their shelters,
that they were highly paid workers.
That's the new theory is to get someone
to build something like that you to see.
The thing is it's so hard to know.
You know,
they might've been slaves that were
taken care of really well.
It's so hard to know because it's so
long ago and they're basing it just on
pottery and bones,
like the type of food that they ate.
They ate well,
but you would have to eat well if you're
moving these giant stones to you.
It would be within your best interest to
keep your slave super healthy.
They have to move stones all day and
it's funny because we just have a theory
of how they did it with ropes.
They really do it.
We don't know.
There's a bunch of different theories
making ramps and stuff.
None of them are really very good
because I think none of them address the
possibility that they had some kind of
technology or understanding that we
don't have anymore.
Whether it's some sort of a machine they
created or some sort of a lever system
they created.
It is entirely possible that like,
look,
when you're talking about your time in
prison or people making tattoo guns out
a wire and you know,
taking something from a broom and
sharpen it and sterilizing it and then
making the suit and doing it for days
like that kind of ingenuity just in
three years of prison.
Imagine 3000 plus years of people trying
to get by and make do during this weird
time where there's no electricity,
there's no engines,
there's no they,
they have the same kind of mind that you
have today that I have today that we're
like modern people,
but they lived in this time where there
was no modern inventions and they
figured out how to make pyramids.
I'll point and then I guess there's like
they say that the way that their son
like hits a certain thing in there.
Well some of them.
Yeah,
but it depends on what time of year
again,
because of that procession of the
equinoxes,
the way the earth wobbles,
it depends on what time of year depends
on what year the cycle is.
You know,
like this procession of the equinox is
also points to the fact that that's
finks at one point in time,
probably I think something like 10,000,
500 years ago,
face the sun,
the face,
the Constellation Leo.
So there's a reason why the lion was
facing in that direction because they
had apparently the Zodiac
constellations.
Uh,
even like way as back as I'm the
Sumerians,
I think they had all the signs of the
Zodiac way back then.
Like they had the fish and the lady with
the skate,
the scales,
all that jazz.
I'm pretty sure they had those
constellations way,
way,
way the fuck back then.
That's it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Said
I could barely put my tent up.
That's not true,
man.
You were talking about,
you know,
living in prison data you would adapt
everywhere.
Yeah.
But
like see,
it's weird.
You made me understand something like
that's what I was kind of like to me I
felt like they were in prison to the
only reason I adapted to it because I
had nothing else to do.
But what was there.
Yeah.
So like they have like what's there.
But like now that like I have all this,
my friend told me this,
he goes,
sorry I talk,
we're going to jump in and out.
And he goes,
hey dog,
when you're in prison,
you have nothing to do,
but you always want to
do something but you can't because
you're confined.
But now that you're home,
don't sit at the fucking house called do
shit.
[inaudible] you been wanting to do
stuff.
But then I catch myself sitting at home
like
so used to this,
get out,
get out.
You're not going to get arrested.
The trap.
So fuck yeah,
I can imagine that they were just like,
there's nothing else to do.
Let's build a pyramid.
And their world.
The world was a prison.
I mean think of how barbaric the world
was 4,500 plus years ago.
How barbaric was the world?
How was the weather?
We do,
we do.
We have proof of how the weather was.
They think that up until around 9,000 bc
it was a tree.
Well from 9,000 BC rather back,
it was a tropical rain forest,
which is really interesting.
They think that it resembled the same
rain forest you see in like the Amazon
thing.
It was beautiful rain forest,
but the climate shifted for whatever
reason,
and that's one of the main arguments
that the sphinx is way older than people
think it is because it has all this
water erosion all throughout the outside
of it.
It's a very hotly debated issue.
Like there's some archeologists that
refuse to believe it because that would
indicate that it was made somewhere,
not just 9,000 bc but thousands of years
before that because it has like
thousands of years of water erosion on
it and they think that erosion is wind
and sand.
It's a real hotly debated subjects and
I'm not really smart enough or educated
enough to make a call either way,
but when I look at it and you listened
to geologists like this guy,
Dr Robert Schoch from Boston University
kind of staked his reputation on it
because he's received a lot of
criticism,
but he's like,
this is thousands of years of rainfall
that's made this a road like this.
Which means,
which means they built that thing
thousands of years.
Even before that,
like we,
we want to think that the Egyptian
civilization neatly arrived around 2,500
BC and there's no way it can be any
earlier than that because you know,
people back then didn't know anything.
Well,
how the fuck did they know how to do it?
Then?
That doesn't make any sense either.
Like,
it doesn't make less sense that people
knew how to do it at 9,000 BC.
It's all crazy with whatever they did
was amazing.
Yeah.
They and they live like ballers.
They always gold if gold everywhere.
You know what I mean?
Look at King Tut sarcophagus.
Sarcophagus covered in fucking gold leaf
and shit.
They were a great artist.
Oh yeah.
Well they wrote in symbols.
They had these weird ways of writing
where they like images or symbols.
So you know,
we look at a word like you look at the
look of the word sandwich and okay see
those letters laid out and they have an
image in your mind and that becomes your
form of language.
That's your written language.
But they had like this,
they had an image based language,
so it's a very different way of thinking
like so did,
uh,
the Mayans had another one,
image based kind
of a language to those imaged based
languages are very bizarre because you
gotta realize like language and the way
it's used shapes the world and one of
the big problems that we're having as
comedians is the subtlety of the English
language and the things that people can
and can't be offended by.
So instead of conveying pure intent,
instead of anything you're saying,
conveying pure intent,
there's this giant variable of what you
can and can't say,
well you shouldn't,
shouldn't be able to say,
you know,
what is offensive to some people?
What is,
you know,
what,
what you think is okay because you feel
this and you feel that there's so much
going on with the English language.
But you got to think that if your
language was based in images,
it would probably have a different feel
to it.
I would wonder what would that feel
would be like.
That's interesting how you said that.
Yeah,
because we sound shit out over there.
It's like,
no,
this is what it means.
They must have obviously have a spoken
language.
That's really weird too.
I don't know what the Egyptian spoke.
I want to say they probably spoke at the
fact that they speak.
If you ask people like,
what did the Egyptian,
the ancient Egyptians speak,
you'd be like,
oh,
I never thought of that.
Egypt would have to be.
Well,
apparently they had a gigantic library,
the library of Alexandria,
and it was burned a long,
long time ago.
Coptic.
Oh,
there it is.
Okay.
17th until late 17th century.
A Dot d,
the form of Coptic.
It was a gypsy.
Okay.
The national language of modern day
Egyptian is Egyptian.
Arabic,
which gradually replaced Coptic as the
language of daily life.
That's bizarre,
right?
Oh,
after the Muslims conquest in Egypt,
Coptic is still used as the literal or
drew litterer.
Litterer liturgical.
The typical liturgical language of the
Coptic Church.
Wow.
Competence.
I would have had a hard time with that
word to what does this King Tut's dagger
made from iron from the sky.
Oh yeah.
They found a dagger.
That was King Tut's.
That came from a media,
they took them beat here and hammered it
out
yet,
but he's,
you know,
there's a guy who does that today.
He makes custom knives made out of
meteors.
If you Google Anthony Bordain had a
knife made out of a media,
how do you get the meteor?
Well,
you can collect them.
There's enough of them land in places
where people have collected them and you
can actually buy media rights.
Literally iron iron from space.
So they take this iron from space and I
fell in to say his name is Klein Klein
knives,
but he's Steve Klein said his name.
No,
that's not his name.
Kramer.
That's it.
Steve Kramer.
Bob Kramer.
Steve Klein is a awesome pool.
Cue Maker.
My bad.
Yes.
Bob Kramer.
Guy.
How do they melt it?
I got a certain degree.
Yeah,
they put it inside of this crazy furnace
and see this is what he's doing here.
Scroll down there so we could look at
it.
There we go.
That's him hammering down these bars of
steel that came from a media.
Right?
And that's how they make a knife.
They take it and they keep hammering it
and they keep throwing it to the fire
and hammering,
and this guy,
Bob Kramer does it all himself.
I mean he does it like the old school
way with obviously with new equipment,
but it's all from the beginning,
like he takes the metal and crafts it
and turns it into this insane looking
knife and at the end of the day,
I mean,
you're cutting your food with a meteor.
Something from space to space.
Apparently it's one,
it's one of the things that were most
terrified of when it comes to asteroids.
Some asteroids are just made out of
iron,
a slice right through.
Just imagine an asteroid that's the size
of Manhattan and it's all iron and a
half coming at us.
Forty 5,000 miles an hour.
Sure,
boom.
You know,
and it just rips the ocean and half go.
I think they said that if an asteroid
that size,
like the one that killed the dinosaurs,
the one that hit the Yucatan,
they said that within seconds it was
miles deep into the earth,
miles deep.
That's like,
that's how
mile deep.
I imagine.
Just imagine that like the impact that
something has to have that don't put
some of the size of a city to go miles
deep in the earth within seconds.
That's.
I would want to see that for some,
like my sick mind,
I would want to see that just to look
down to see what's in there.
Yeah.
I've seen those animated ones.
I do online.
You get to look at like an ad,
but you know that's not really
happening.
It doesn't really have the same effect.
Like you'll okay.
I,
yeah,
I get it.
I get that's what it would look like,
but I think seeing it happen,
seeing that thing coming down,
what's fucked up is man,
you look up at the moon and this is
covered in craters covered.
They go,
well the moon is just,
man,
why is the moon keep getting hit?
We keep getting hit too.
We just covered in plants and shit.
We don't see it anymore.
We got water and plants that have made
us forget the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere too,
so it burns up.
We lose a lot of the asteroids that are
coming in because of the atmosphere or
the asteroids,
meteorites,
whatever.
They are media whores,
but the moon doesn't have any of that
shit so it comes crashing down,
but I just think that we put out a bunch
of times.
We've been hit a bunch of times.
We just forgot.
I,
I've never even thought of that.
I'm tripping out on there right now like
that.
That sounds.
I know the Swedes good,
but like I'm fucking like,
wow.
He's very sweet.
Very good.
And like speaking to the moon,
like remember the Mayans discovered that
the rabbit was on the moon.
Have you seen that?
That's their signal.
Like they say there's a rabbit face on
the moon.
The problem here is don't we always see
the same side of the moon to the moon
doesn't spin,
correct?
I don't think it does.
I think the moon does not spin.
The moon faces us the same way all the
time.
Pretty sure.
So that'll make sense.
The man on the moon,
there was some science thing from a long
time ago,
man,
where they thought they saw canals on
Mars.
They were convinced when this first
started looking at Mars,
there was canals and they were like,
oh yeah,
that's what they thought.
They thought they were not right,
but they were like,
Holy Shit,
we're looking at a civilization on Mars.
Like people were preparing themselves to
make contact with the Martians.
I trip out on us as humans.
We always want to go find something else
and go kick it with something else.
That's like,
fuck that.
No,
there's someone over there.
I know there's someone at Mars.
We keep knocking,
but how open.
I know,
I remember one time I had this thought
where I was like,
what if humans are so smooth that we've
already been on Mars and Saturn and all
that and we just fuck them up so we
can't live there no more,
and that's why we're here and that's why
we keep looking for other ones to fuck
up.
Well,
if we found someone over there and they
talk shit,
we definitely fuck them.
That's a fact.
And tell me we fuck up people in
Afghanistan.
We wouldn't fuck up people on the moon.
Does the moon rotate?
Yeah,
it does.
It does.
It spins synchronous rotation.
Oh,
it spins as we spin.
So we don't see it spinning.
Oh,
interesting.
So we see the same side every time.
That's one of the things that I was
going to.
The moon orbits the Earth once every 27
point three to two days.
It also takes apparently 27 days to the
moon to rotate one on its access.
As a result,
the moon does not seem to be spinning,
but appears to observers from earth to
be keeping almost perfectly still.
Scientists call this synchronous
rotation.
That's cool.
That's fucking cool.
How does all that happen?
And stay in sequence and rock and roll
off.
I couldn't love it.
Well,
how's it float up there?
How come it's not Lenna are fucking
head.
None of that makes.
That's like explain that.
How come the fucking asteroids come
flying in?
But uh,
the moon just hovers.
What if the moon just decided to jack us
hatred forever.
Motherfuckers and takes off,
you know.
But they say that the moon is like a
residue of when the earth was created,
that there was earth one,
the scientists have a model of earth and
earth to an earth.
One was like this giant ball of fire and
gases,
and we got hit with another planet like
in the early days of development of the
earth.
We like another planet collided with
Earth.
And that's what created the moon.
And that's what stabilized its orbit.
And that's the reason why apparently we
can survive is because if it wasn't for
the moon,
we wouldn't have a steady atmosphere.
We wouldn't have a steady temperature,
wouldn't have a steady orbit,
we would vary too widely.
And we would have never developed.
We'd all be like tardigrades in the
bottom of the ocean or some shit.
Some weird little indisputable nuclear
single cell multicellular organisms or
something at his fucking crazy.
Yeah.
The,
what's now somehow Jana.
I'm trying to find that the only thing
that comes up when I type in earth and
earth to is a lot of stuff about DC
comics.
Oh No,
it was from um,
no,
no.
It was,
um,
the earth wanted earth to.
They actually do.
They actually talked about it in the
Sumerian tax,
which is really kind of fascinating.
The Sumerian texts talked about Earth's
collision,
that there was a planet,
it's called,
like things called the planet's Tmr and
Marduke and they collided and it created
a earth and one of the.
And it also created the moon.
What's interesting,
what's interesting about that is that
they had figured this out 6,000
something years ago.
Like this is even older than the
pyramids.
Like,
oh yeah,
it's really old.
The ancient Sumerians were the oldest as
far as like what we currently know of
us,
you know,
it changes all the time.
They find new stuff all the time.
But as far as what the archeologists
know of today is the oldest written
language,
the oldest mathematics,
like a gang of that stuff is thought to
be from that part of the world.
So the same part of the world also knew
about all the planets in the right,
order it in the right size.
It's really strange that a telescope
with.
We don't know what they knew,
but they have had a.
They had these drawings in clay tablets
where they had the picture,
the sun,
and they would picture it.
It would have earth who'd had Venus had
Jupiter have all these planets like the
big ones.
Where were the big ones were the smaller
ones where they're the right size.
It's crazy.
Like how the fuck did they know?
This is kind of like that.
Like all right,
make a right over there and go like if
they're going somewhere,
it's almost like they somehow or another
we could see them.
How they could see them.
I don't understand.
I don't.
I don't know what they figured out.
They figured out something.
What is this?
Jamie
says Zacharias petitions or a diagram of
what happened.
See,
there's a problem with switching though.
I'm obviously not a fucking scholar,
but the ones who are,
they go over his stuff and they.
A lot of them don't agree with it and
there's an actual website.
It's called [inaudible] is wrong,
might be.org or.com and it's all like
poking holes in his stuff.
His stuff is fun as fuck though.
It's fun to believe because he thinks
that we were created by aliens and the
aliens came from a planet called Nibiru
and they came down here and they did
genetic manipulations with lower
primates and they created human beings.
That's pretty crazy.
As the best.
It's so fun.
I tripped out how people say that the
Egyptians were having sex with aliens
because of the old highly griffes.
They found like the aliens with their
penises out with like they do
civilization.
I think you might've been breeding some.
Yeah,
for real.
Yeah.
We had alien penises and the
hieroglyphs.
Yeah.
I thought
I seen it all.
Now,
and I read this.
I've read a book in prison,
caught the biggest secret by David
Steiner,
Einstein,
something like that.
And He.
Did they show you the pictures in there?
Wow.
I haven't seen that.
Uh hmm.
It was it.
David Ike wasn't David.
It might have been.
It's been a long time.
It was just because you only got certain
books,
but David likes that guy that thinks if
I was him,
I don't even know if he thinks it's
anymore,
but he used to think that the top
leaders of the world,
we're all the reptilians.
Yes.
That's the guy.
Yeah.
I don't think that's correct.
I just tell you what,
I tripped out on
those.
Those are three times for sure that I
would want to go back to.
If you had to choose a place in time
where you can go back and just check it
out,
what would it be?
Me.
I'd want to go back to the dinosaur time
was a good call.
I fucked up.
I should give up.
One of my stores are going to give up
gangs for the dinosaur days.
Nah,
Genghis Gangsta to give up somebody.
I definitely want to go back.
I don't know.
Just this fucked
it was their land and then um,
just because I'm Mexican,
I'd want to go back to like the
Cortez came.
Yeah.
You got done
that time.
Montezuma days?
Yeah.
At all.
No,
it's crazy,
man.
Whenever they're building shit in Mexico
City,
there was like digging into the ground
and they got to halt construction.
Stopped,
stop.
They find something funny.
Shit.
They found a temple.
They find jewelry.
They find something.
It's all over the place.
I guess there's this new,
uh,
airplane that shoots.
It's like,
you know,
you could do an ultrasound on a body
that at the airplane radar does an
ultrasound on the dirt or whatever.
The floor,
the ground,
and they're trying to find temples over
there now.
Eddie Bravo is right.
There's that bonus was raised when the
sky try to find money.
That's what it is.
He was just wrong with the method man.
I think there's a gang of shit under
there,
but it's crazy because it's not that
long ago.
No,
it's not.
You know what I mean?
Cortez was one that was a 14 hundreds.
When did Cortez come here now would save
the 14 hundreds and then the reason that
the temple's ain't even there no more is
because Catholicism took it out.
Catholicism who came in and then they
buried the temples and built churches
over the temple's not crazy.
Like they built churches over the,
that's a big thing in Egypt to they're
finding like one period of construction
and then on top of that period of
construction there's some newer,
more modern shit.
And as they go onto the monitor,
they're like,
well they built the modern shit on top
of the older shit.
Like what the fuck were they doing?
But they did it a gang of times in
history.
They think,
well,
are we doing it right now?
Like are we building a new coliseum over
the old fucking coliseum?
We do.
We tear down houses.
People literally by what they call a
tear down house.
He bought a house.
It's and,
but it's on a
nice lot and you know,
it's a big investment honey.
But I think a tear downs the right move.
He tear down that house and build a
beautiful house.
And that spot as an original foundation.
Yeah man,
that's a sad thing because um,
when I was doing construction on the
east coast,
you would run across these buildings
that had these old school nails.
Their nails galvanized,
right?
Well,
was there were,
there were like a wedge.
It wasn't like a circle with a straight
line,
like you know,
a nail has a point at the end of it,
but then it's a perfect kind of a
perfect cylinder all the way up to the
top and it's got a flathead.
Yes.
These old nails weren't like that.
These old nails were like a wedge.
It was like a steel wedge because they
were making them in a blacksmith so the
nails had like a top flat part where you
could hammer it in,
but instead of having like a long
straight cylinder,
it was actually a wedge and the pointy
end was the bottom of the wedge and they
would tap it in like that and that.
That's what a nail was back then.
So when I was doing construction and you
would pull these,
you could tell when you were going into
an old ass building.
Yeah,
that's what it looked like.
See,
that's an old nail like that sales I
get.
I pulled a gang of those out of
buildings when I was a kid,
but it's kind of sad in a way because
these houses that were made this way,
like some day people would love to see
that and go,
well,
this is like a piece of history to see
an old house that was built with the way
they would do the,
uh,
insulation to.
They have this like white shit that was
like in between these boards.
It wasn't,
it wasn't.
They didn't have a fiberglass back then
or anything,
so it was like,
it's white plaster.
He Shit.
It wasn't like pink,
no pink stuff.
The fiberglass stuff.
Okay.
That's the stuff that you have to put in
addicts and shit.
Yeah.
You did construction that inside that
house.
Gut Shit inside the house is not fun if
you're doing an attic.
I did an addict once that,
that had the fiberglass shit in it.
Get it in your skin.
You get all itchy everywhere.
You're itchy and you sweat and sweat
opens up your pores and the fiberglass
shit gets in there.
Can I ask you a question?
When you were stripping the nails from
the woodwork,
why were you taking the nails out where
you were working?
Were tearing something down,
putting something in its place.
I don't remember whether or not it was
a,
um,
a remodel or whether or not they were
putting an addition on or something like
that.
But whenever you'd have to go into the
walls of these buildings,
you could tell right away because they
had these,
I forget,
I forget what you would call those long
thin boards that were stacked on top of
each other.
As soon as you go through the plaster,
you feel the plaster and you would know
as the old house because it was like a
plaster instead of a wall board.
When you go to a new house,
they have that wall wallboard stuff
which is,
you know,
gypsum board,
it's kind of thin.
It doesn't have a lot of like mass to
it.
And then behind that you would have all
the other stuff and then insulation and
shit.
But in these old houses it wasn't like
that.
It was like these.
I can't call them thin,
just really thin long boards and in
between there's this white plaster he
shit and there was plaster over the of
shingles shingles,
but like little thin boards like a,
you know,
like,
not even a half inch thick by like maybe
an interest so wide and they had those
kinds of nails that put them into the
studs.
I got you now.
Yeah.
And so he'd pull those nails out and you
don't always recognize.
I'm like,
wow,
there's an old fucking house because New
England,
that was an old place,
you know what I mean?
You could go to England today and see
there's graves that you could visit that
are from like the 17 hundreds.
Yeah.
They have a grape still there.
Yeah,
they're still there.
You know,
it's slowly but surely the numbers are
getting more eroded by the atmosphere
and stuff.
But it's still there.
You still read them.
Some of them are kind of faint.
You think in 100 years,
like they're going to have to like
discover a new method for burying us
because it's stupid to bury people.
It's stupid.
The only reason why we should bury
people in,
well,
it's also what we're doing is we are,
we're keeping the natural process of us
becoming useful to the world because
like when things die,
those things are absorbed by the
environment.
There's a system in place set up.
I mean if you just buried someone,
if you just opened up a whole,
put them in the ground and bury them.
The natural course of order would take
place.
The bacteria and their body would break
down their body.
The,
the soil would absorb their body.
They'd become fertilizer like every
animal has from the beginning of time.
But we're so weird.
We want to fill our dead bodies up with
some shit that keeps them from rotting.
And then we put makeup on them and dress
them up in their best clothes with Mike,
my grandfather,
when he died,
they put one of those,
um,
crucifixes with the,
what are those things called?
The crucifix with the Rosary,
with the rosary about and like,
like he never even went to church.
Like,
what are you doing here?
what is this?
He's clutching his face.
He's got this.
He's so,
this does no feel to him,
you know,
he's gone and they're going to take him
and they're going to put them in a box
and then they're going to buried in the
ground and it's probably,
you go dig it out today if I probably
wanted to go in there today,
his body still in there because those
things don't rot because they're filled
up with formaldehyde and all crazy.
It's real weird.
The only reason why it makes sense as to
prove murder cases and shit like that.
I mean that's,
that's about it.
Like maybe if the death is weird,
the death is weird.
You should probably like,
you know,
he was,
he thought like you can't prove it yet,
but something,
something went down because they've
caught people for murders by going and
digging up the bodies and finding
arsenic and their system or something
like that.
They've done that.
That's weird though.
But like,
I dunno,
it's Kinda like a case close homies.
I should've got away with it now if you
bear it and you can't bring them back.
Yeah.
But if they catch you,
so you're thinking layer convict.
You didn't get away.
No,
no.
I beat the game.
He's in the ground that.
Come on.
Fuck.
It's just a.
it's a barbaric way of.
It's.
It's,
it's an inhumane way.
It's.
It's not a smart thing.
It's a custom plus.
It's
a giant racket.
It's a huge financial racket.
Joey Diaz as the first one to explain
that to me,
it goes dark.
The wars fucking racket that nobody ever
talks about funerals.
Think about it.
What the fuck you going to do?
What the fuck are you going to do?
You're going to spend that money though,
and he goes to that cheap box.
It's like $1,000,
$2,000.
You've got to pay the funeral costs,
you got to pay for this service,
and he's explaining everything.
You have to have a plot of land.
I'm like,
what?
Oh my God,
I never thought about that.
And he's like,
it obliterates people.
It obliterates them.
It puts them in massive debt.
Thousands of dollars in debt like that.
Mandatories.
Yeah,
and it's mandatory and it's mandatory.
I mean,
I guess there must be some sort of
programs in place to take care of bodies
and people can't afford anything.
I mean I would imagine there is,
but just the practice itself,
the fact that it's not just common,
it's standard.
That's the standard practice.
It's a crazy way to take care of bodies,
man.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Like I remember like telling my kids
like a,
if there's any way you can make it
happen,
I want to be buried in this fucking
backyard right here.
If you could make it happen,
but then they're gonna go to jail.
Yeah,
because
I guess there's like certain walls.
Well the should be because if you have a
well and you put your body and your body
rots into that,
well it gets people sick.
People have died from that.
So that is something where I used to
live in Burbank.
There was a,
a gravestone of a dead baby that
underneath the steps going up to our
apartment buildings,
like seven apartment Jesus random street
and it was like a,
the,
the birth and the death date or seven
days apart.
It was like 50,
70 years.
He goes a long time ago.
It wasn't like it just happened either.
It's super weird that just built stairs
over top of it.
We're really,
really weird spot.
So strange.
Jesus,
you know what else is strange?
Your voice coming through that shitty
wire active before and it worked even
earlier.
It was working fine.
I need to just replace it.
Okay,
no worries.
It was weird though,
right?
Yeah,
man.
It's a strange thing when you drive by
this beautiful plot of land and saw
these cement stone sticking out of the
ground.
Let the.
It's also weird too that it has to be
public.
It has to like your dad has to be buried
in some giant field with all these other
people's dead people like why?
Why do we have to all be together in
death?
Only
death only.
You get a small spot and then a couple
of feet overs another person and you
have to be buried in these areas where
we designate that people go to cry and
drop flowers is goofy as fuck.
It's one of those things.
It's just always.
We've always done it that way so we
don't stop and think like what kind of.
It's kind of like marriage.
He's the same shit.
Similar.
Both of them.
You keep the death.
Yeah.
It's just weird that nobody does
anything else.
Like one of the.
You could not get married if you choose
to.
If you go,
you know,
fuck marriage,
man.
I don't want to be legally entangled
with some person if I want to break up
with him.
I just wanted to be able to just leave
one at my own choice.
I can't do that to death,
but that's kind of the same way.
Like when when people die,
like you have to give them,
you have to do something,
you have to either cremate them.
Oh you have to.
And I think even when you cremate them,
I think you have to do the formaldehyde
think first.
Yeah,
I'm kind of scared.
I kinda told my kids I want them to
cremate me too because I was,
I don't want to be maggots eating meat
and shit like that.
No.
Now I don't know.
That's the way to go.
Maggots is the way to go.
The way to go is the fucking
formaldehyde because Formaldehyde,
like whatever use that you would have
for.
Although the organisms that would
normally devour any sort of dead living
creature,
a creature that becomes dead,
that's not.
They don't get to eat anymore.
For some reason,
we've decided that they don't get to
consume your body.
Like your body is more important than
all the other things that it consumes.
We're part of the ECO.
It's one more way that we've separated
ourselves from the system.
This natural system that we're in,
we're.
We're,
we're delusional.
Like we think we're not a part of this
system because we have houses and air
conditioning and I go to the supermarket
from our food.
We're a part of the system for sure,
but that's one more way we separate
ourselves.
Imagine if animals had cemeteries and
shit that would be fucked up.
There'd be no room for anything.
Then they're dying like crazy.
Imagine the cemeteries are just all the
birds that cats kill.
You will realize what kind of mass
murder of monsters you're living with.
You.
Everywhere you go,
he'd be like,
what is going on?
Like this is all the cats killing birds.
They just look everywhere.
You wouldn't be able to walk everywhere
you would walk.
It'd be like a little gravestone for a
bird that was killed by a cat.
You know,
I,
I agree with you now as far as like,
yeah man,
don't get cremated.
It's made process.
You're supposed to go in there and just.
It's the way it goes.
I think the problem is diseases though.
I think what they're worried about is
what we're talking about,
but I don't think if you're.
I guess if they formaldehyde you up and
they drop you in the ground,
you don't rot so you don't leak into the
water system.
He just sorta like just sit there and
prune up.
I don't think you're right for a long
ass time,
but if you did rot,
I could see that.
If you somehow or another gotten a water
system,
if there's a.
like,
especially if you're dealing with a
city,
that's when it becomes impractical.
Right?
Because if you're like New York City,
small spot less than,
what is it?
Like what does New York have like 7
million or 8 million people live in the
city,
something crazy like that.
They're all stuffed into this area,
you know,
way smaller than La and they were just
jammed in there.
Right?
What would they do if they had dead
bodies?
They're all stacked on top of each
other.
What are they going to do with the dead
bodies?
They almost have to cremate them or have
to embalm them.
Like you can't burry him anywhere.
You got to take them out of town and
throw them in the ocean.
What are you gonna do?
That's crazy.
Should be all thrown in the
ocean.
Right?
Should have a law.
Like you only get out.
You got to be 10 miles off shore,
but you're going to get eaten in there
by that.
Doug,
ed,
my crabs,
lobsters and shit.
And then in turn you'll find a good spot
to catch lobsters.
That's what it used to.
I remember my Grandpa,
he made the best stone crabs.
We've caught stone crabs right where
grandpa died or were we dropped his body
off.
That's what they did with Osama bin
Laden.
Right?
Chuck them in the ocean.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy.
It was crazy.
That's why I trip out.
I was like,
dude,
that's.
People are like,
our president is not black.
I like,
he killed that full and throw them over
the boat.
That's gangster as full kill someone.
Takes them and get the fuck outta here.
Dot.
I wonder what the.
Who made the decision to do it that way?
Because it was a two day decision was
because I guess Muslim,
they have like a real special ritual
like two days after the body has to be
done something.
Oh,
interesting.
So they did it quick.
Yeah,
the whole.
Well you're not supposed to do that in
the Muslim faith.
I don't think you're supposed to throw
the bodies overboard.
I think that's one of the reasons why
they did it.
That's one of those ones that's going to
go down in history.
You know when people are going to look
back at historical moments there just
seem crazy in the future.
I just killed them and thrown in the
ocean.
Ooh,
whoa.
It's dark.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess they said they didn't want him
to be a mortar or they didn't want to
martyr martyr know.
Yeah,
I mean it makes sense.
I guess.
I mean they would understand it better
than I would.
I would just be speculating as to what
you should and shouldn't do with the
body of a mastermind terrorist that you
just killed.
They've been looking for for years that
was living in the house.
Imagine that his took his brain and
they've been working on probably what
happened.
I like Saddam.
Oh,
the hunting.
That motherfucker.
They probably fed to his dogs.
They're smart.
Yeah.
That what they did.
Well they,
you know,
Saddam,
his sons used to have dogs.
They would throw people to the dogs and
feed them to the dogs.
He was like Ramsay Bolton from game of
thrones,
like legitimately is his kids were
psychopaths,
total murderers,
mass murderers.
They would.
They would find women that we're about
to get married,
take them from their husbands,
rape them,
and then feed them to the dogs.
I think I've seen that in a movie.
Yeah.
Probably buried his body near the
graves.
Of his other family members.
You got lucky.
It's hard part of the world,
man.
Again,
it's like we were talking about that
part of the world so much different than
Santa Monica.
Hell yeah.
You know,
and it really is a perspective thing,
isn't it?
Yeah.
It's a trip like
everyone's all talking about like,
oh,
over there in Saudi Arabia,
women in them,
women don't have rights.
Women don't do this.
Or women do is cook and clean.
I was just like,
be happy.
You are where you are there not
tripping.
They're living their life over there.
Do what?
Am I against it?
Yeah.
But they haven't changed what they
wanted to do.
They might be tripping hard.
They just can't do shit about it.
I understand that people on the outside
look at it and see it's horrible and uh,
it'll all because of that,
because of people's attitudes.
I think that's what changes things
because people get upset at it because
then that word gets back to them.
The rest of the world,
chicks can go to school the rest of the
world that can drive.
They don't have to dress up in those
outfits.
They can do whatever the fuck they want.
They're treated just like regular people
like the rest of the world.
Most of the rest of the world.
That's where it's going.
You guys are stuck in a bad spot.
Do you see the thing that happened with
North Korea?
They let the world accidentally opened
up their websites.
They only have 28 websites.
Yeah,
I didn't read up on it.
I seen it like a little glimpse of it.
How crazy is that?
That they have 28 websites.
Fuck bad.
Like what do they have?
What the fuck did they show?
Like what they had?
Anything?
No,
I don't know.
I mean obviously it's in those Korean
symbols.
I wouldn't be able to read it,
but I don't know if anybody's translated
it.
What they had.
I haven't read that yet.
Jamie view on no house has a laptop,
no house and all.
I'd have a personal computer.
It says an airline ticket agency for air
core.
Choreo Choreo,
a website for a group called national
unity.
A website for Kim Il Sung University
website for the Voice of Korea news
organization,
a news website for the government of
North Korea.
That place is fucking crazy that that
exists today.
That there is a country that is right
next to another country that looks
exactly like them.
Like North Koreans and South Koreans are
fucking Koreans,
right?
They.
They look super similar,
right?
It's not like Mexicans and Africans.
It's not like two distinctly different
looking kinds of people know that
they're incredibly identical,
right?
But above them,
they have North Korea and they're living
in a dictatorship,
a military,
straight up dictatorship.
The entire country is under the heel of
a dictator,
a crazy military,
ruthless dictator with nuclear bombs
detonated nuclear bombs and tests and
shit.
Then the other side,
you've got people making the best
electronics in the world.
If I go flying innovation,
they're all getting.
They're all getting surgery.
You get their eyes bigger.
They're and all that shit.
No,
they're good.
They're eyes bigger.
No,
dude,
it is a huge problem in Korea is a
plastic surgery.
I don't shouldn't say huge problem
because then it's not like they die.
They just look different.
They're get plastic surgery is a huge
fad in,
in South Korea,
so they're not getting their titties
done and they're getting everything
done,
I'm sure,
but one of the things they're doing is
they're getting their eyes done so that
they look more American.
What's.
What's the process?
Do they cut of the eyelid eyelid?
Yeah.
How?
How,
how do they,
how do they use it?
They used to look like that's the look
like now.
Little girls.
Fucking girls.
Let's start looking like Anna Mae.
It's really strange,
man.
It's a real strange like that.
They,
they,
they become super hot looking.
Even if they were like not that hot,
it's very,
it's just a bizarre practice man.
See that's where they do cut down there
and cut down there and then you can see
what she looks like when it's all done,
but it's,
you know,
I mean it's not like,
oh that girl got a lot of work done.
She had her chin shaved down.
She had her eyes done and her ears.
Yeah.
Well I don't know what her hair looked
pretty big.
Still her.
It's a plastic surgeries critique.
Pretty crazy what they can do.
They can alter your shape.
I said that girl.
Oh my God,
don't do.
They shaved the fuck out of her jaw.
That's insane.
They turned to a new hottie.
Amazing.
Amazing what they can do.
Right.
But apparently it's super common.
Super Common in Korea.
Wow.
Look at the before and after.
That's weird.
Yeah.
When I met with the girl now she don't
got no baby pictures.
I don't fuck around with them.
Say you need to have some baby pictures.
Yeah.
Did.
And I used to work at a strip club.
I was like,
this dude,
he was hot.
I didn't know he was the dude,
but like he'd always hugged me from the
back and someone is like,
hey dog,
this guy right here,
he's a retired.
This girl's a guy girl was a guy.
He was on like transexuals.com,
Orange County,
Kala.
And I remember her stage name was Monica
and mean one time I was high and I was,
hey man,
I've never ever been like,
grabbed so hard like that thrown out of
my chair.
Wow.
She got aggressive yet I remember after
that,
always saying a dog.
I need to see baby pictures.
Everybody.
Yeah.
There's some little trick you,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
You will never know unless they choose
to tell you.
Like if you see what they're doing right
now with chins and eyes.
Imagine what they could do to your
nether regions.
Yeah.
It's going to get crazier.
They get conjure up
vagina.
That looks like a work of art.
I'm sure it was probably like the best
in the world.
It's probably a guy who's like,
you know,
the Frank Frazetta of surgical vaginas
just makes this incredible work of art.
Puts the memory foam back in.
I wonder if they've ever done that.
I wonder if anybody's ever had like a
vaginal implant to make your vagina
tighter.
You know,
like they'll get boob jobs,
like you get a breast implant.
Sure.
Boom.
Spoke out more in something like that.
But they rejuvenation thing.
Yeah.
But I think they just tighten up the
whole.
Yeah,
like the inside they cut.
I think the way they do,
and this is going to sound horrible
folks.
I think they cut you and then they the
two sides and stitch you the fuck up and
I think it hurts like a mother fucker.
The things people are doing to satisfy
each other.
Yeah.
We need.
We need more constantly.
Constantly has to get better,
more,
more tart or plus a magnetometer.
Surgery.
Time for surgery,
increase in vaginal tightening,
surgeries,
worries doctors.
Oh my God worries him.
It's going to make Dick Shrink.
We should let natural selection tickets
course.
Yeah.
I mean,
who cares?
I think you can.
They do it.
I don't know why not.
If I was one of those girls and I had a
crazy big fucked up John,
they shrank it down and all of a sudden
now it became hot as fuck and everybody
wanted to talk to me.
I think I spend my money wisely.
I would go for that.
Yeah,
I mean exactly.
I mean,
if I had to do it,
I do it too,
but isn't it bizarre that there's a very
specific shape that we like and we don't
like when it comes to people,
whether it's the shape of the nose or
shape of the jaw,
like we agree so much.
There's too much.
Too much jaw,
too much job.
Like there's a lot of variables.
We don't like long hair.
Long hair doesn't bother me.
Shorter.
Short doesn't and bottom either.
Either one's okay.
Like those characteristics.
We have a lot of room.
Oh,
she has curls.
Okay.
Who gives a fuck?
Dreadlocks.
Whatever.
Who Cares?
She shaved her head.
Does she look good?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But like a big judge.
He got a big job.
Fuck that.
Fuck.
That.
Can't deal with that.
Look like that.
Look for whatever reason that looked
freaks us out.
Like the hair.
It's like inconsequential because it's
not.
It's a part of you sorta,
but you cut it.
You don't even feel it.
It's kind of weird that it even grows in
the first place.
Kind of weird lion's mane.
Are you growing off the top of your
fucking head?
It's weird.
Right?
So we don't care if all the variables.
Girls can have pink hair and shit,
you know?
Yeah.
They get dick with any color hair right
now.
Yeah.
But not with a big jaw.
No.
Fucked up shoulders.
I think shoulders.
Job is going to be the next one too.
Big.
Bigger shoulders like Tommy hearns type
shoulder.
Intimidating.
Like some Lennox Lewis shoulders.
Yeah.
You don't one time like when she's
wearing her purse and it's like a right
by her ear.
Maybe you want to conquer though.
You don't call.
I've had those.
Yeah.
I've had some big chicks like gangster
bitches that are fine and cool and is
fucking ruthless.
Got To be real careful when you grow up
and kick your ass or maybe you can kick
your ass or at least hold her own.
Watch your p's and q's.
I got with the stripper once.
I was like six,
three.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
She played volleyball and swam.
Wow.
And Oh man,
I don't.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm average sized,
you know,
but I got manhandled
like I was young,
we were play wrestling and I was just
like,
thrown in like,
fuck.
Yeah.
I just kept my cool with that girl.
Wow.
She was much stronger than you and it
was awesome.
Was like,
it was like an extra pump.
It was weird.
Damn.
She'd be my vein pop out or you're
getting excited.
Oh,
I remember that bitch.
That's super athletes.
Yeah.
Like NBA player.
If you get a dobby,
an NBA player to meet with an NBA
player,
what kind of super athletes would you
get?
Like,
good Lord.
Yeah know.
Or you know who I met.
That's a super athlete.
What does that volleyball player woman's
name.
She's very attractive.
This is like a,
the one that.
Yes.
Gabrielle Reece.
She's,
she's huge,
giant,
super athlete.
If you could get her and made her up
with a brock Lesnar,
how are you kidding me?
What kind of super athlete would you do
if you could get Gabrielle Reece and
Brock Lesnar and make them together?
Shaquille o'neal.
Lisa.
Leslie?
Yes.
Super Athletes.
You know,
there's some fucking super athletes out
there in the world too.
There's so many athletes that are just.
You just go,
what?
How is that?
How is that even a person?
How's that person?
How is that the same thing as me?
You know?
It's the way their bread now,
the way they're taught,
that way they're coached.
It's crazy.
There's like kids that are 13 years old
taking creatine,
my friends,
Hey,
can you get money from my son's team and
he's 13.
Oh,
you're giving this kid create a teen.
I wonder if that's even healthy.
That's probably an unhealthy.
I don't even think 13 year old kids are
supposed to be lifting weights.
Right?
They're only supposed to do like a
calisthenics and things like that.
Like they think that weight itself can
actually fuck with their bone growth
because their bodies aren't designed to.
I wonder if that's been disproven.
I don't know.
I was just talking with my dad about
that the other day,
literally because there's a kid my age
that when we were growing up started
lifting a little earlier than everyone
else and he just all through high
school.
You fucked everyone up.
He was,
because he was that he had to write.
She was ahead of us all.
He was a monster because of just because
of that and I don't think he would have
been smaller now than he was then.
He,
his dad,
small.
He would have been small as whole life
anyway.
Maybe,
Huh?
Yeah.
Who knows?
I don't know if it's a bullshit meth or
not.
See if you can find out has the same
mill and they don't play,
but don't shoot the ball after you work
out.
Don't shoot around and misses up your
jump shot.
That's.
No,
it's the best thing because you're
shooting tired.
There's some people that look at it that
way.
That's what they would say about archery
to.
Shouldn't do archery after you lift
weights.
Yeah.
Because,
um,
you don't want to have control of your
muscles and your muscles are fatigued.
It's harder to control fatigue game
fourth quarter.
I see both.
That was a philosophy and a lot of
Jujitsu schools you would do a lot of
calisthenics,
especially old school schools.
You do a lot of calisthenics and you'd
be fucking completely worn out before
you ever start sparring.
Oh,
so before the beginning of class,
we push ups and hip scoots hip escapes
and go down the Mat and back.
He'd be doing while crab bear walks,
walk on your hands and feet,
that kind of shit,
and you get completely pushups,
sit ups and by burning you out with
calisthenics,
you were forced to use technique when
you rolled
and then that you would spar.
After all that.
Yeah,
you would do technique,
you would do drills and then you'd wind
up sparring,
but they don't.
Most places don't do it that way
anymore.
Most places believe the best way to
learn is actually just warm up.
Do drills go over the technical aspects
of it.
Then just spar hard and that you should
be fresh when you practice and
technique.
What does that saying?
This is an article from live strong and
I just went to dismissing the myths,
get to the end of it,
and it basically says that lets you read
it.
Okay.
Contrasts with suggestions of stunted
growth among young weightlifters.
Betsy Keller points out that
weightlifting may be more effective than
other forms of exercise in promoting
bone growth and density among
adolescents.
Huh?
So it actually might be healthier for
them.
These researchers found that
testosterone injections increase both
bone length and density,
suggesting that weightlifting's impact
on testosterone may be beneficial.
Huh?
Veterans Administration Medical Center
supports evidence in 2008 study.
Interesting.
It says it might allow you to grow
taller than you would have.
Hm.
Interesting.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Who knows man,
but you wouldn't want to fuck your kid
up.
You know.
That's the thing.
Like,
I've seen people that have their kids
totally jacked at an early age.
I'm like,
boy.
Again,
like how much pressure you put on that
little guy?
Is that what he wants to do?
Your kid wants to do squats.
Yeah.
I kinda think they don't.
Fuck.
I had all that pressure on me,
man.
I'm probably used to wake me up like in
sixth grade.
Come on,
walk.
You're going to go watch the freshmen
practice.
I was like,
why do I gotta go to this practice?
Older brothers,
man.
Make tough kids though.
Do you look at a kid who was like the
youngest brother has got a bunch of
brothers at fuck with them.
Those dudes usually not a handle
themselves because you'd grown up in a
combat situation.
Your brothers are fucking with you
constantly have.
We're all yet.
We're all a year apart.
That's terrible.
That's chaos.
It's that little Hercules' guy from a
couple of years ago.
Yeah.
That's what he looks like now.
You grew up and gave up on him.
He gave up on lifting weights
inside edition story on him last year.
Poor little guy.
So it looked like
those myostatin inhibitor things or
maybe or.
No,
they don't have that.
Like in terms of like a supplement w w,
some people born with mild stat
inhibitors and makes a grow much more
muscle.
You bought as or regulate the growth of
muscle the way ours does.
What do you mean some,
it's some weird genetic freak that they
found in dogs called whippets and some
cows that somehow or another,
when they're breeding these dogs,
they uh,
they develop this genetic variation in
what's called a milestone and inhibitor.
And it allows for some strange reason,
like there's a real dog,
this is a whippet that has this mild
staten inhibitor issue and these are
some cows that have a two.
And what it is is they just grow way
more muscle.
So look at the size of that cow.
It's incredible.
Right?
So they figured out how to do it in
mice.
Like they figured out how to introduce
these genes to mice and they develop
these mice.
They live longer,
they are much more muscular,
they have more endurance.
That's what their bodies look like.
Yeah.
So really kind of fascinating because it
points to this idea that these little
animals through this myostatin inhibitor
are like super animals.
They become like super mys.
Like that's what it looked like.
Look at that little one on the right
with all the muscles.
It's crazy man.
Second Simone Mouse.
It's like a David Tula stacked up mouse.
George.
We just did three hours man too.
That it's over.
Hey,
it was fun.
Great Stories,
man.
Thank you.
Didn't.
We didn't even tell all of them,
but there was a gang of them.
You were telling the store will have to
do it again.
Yeah,
you educate me like crazy right now.
I was just talking with fun man.
And uh,
you're going to be in Bria next weekend.
Yeah.
So what's the date?
Is October 29th and October 30th.
Me and red band or doing the late shows
at the Improv.
Beautiful.
Bright Improv is the shit that should be
a really funny show.
Yeah.
It's funny dude.
Redmond's funding.
So that should be a great time.
Thanks for coming brother.
Really appreciate it.
It was a lot of fun.
All right folks.
We'll see you next week.
Bye Bye.
Three hours doing that shit.